[Music]
is
hey stay tuned for a debate Night Live
stream live you can use the hashtag
Crowder debate night we have a promo
code drinking game rules to follow but
number two here uh Gerald Morgan CEO sat
down just a little bit earlier today
with uh Vivic remas swam you know his
name uh to discuss his thoughts and
predictions on the debate so 10 minutes
and then we go live but enjoy this
interview with America's favorite
[Music]
Indian look the field is definitely
narrowing and uh I know that we're we've
covered a number of topics already in
the debate so far what what topics are
you focusing on and kind of preparing
for for tonight's
debate yeah I mean look I there's every
topic matters but right now there's a
few things that are going on in the
world one is the Republicans got
trounced again yeah interestingly every
election since you know what 2018 2020
2022 now 2023 which was actually a
pretty meaningful election in my home
state was very disappointed with the
results I mean it wasn't even close in
Ohio uh on measure on issue number one
in particular that Republicans or the
conservative or pro-life cost should
have had an alternative that was on the
ballot it wasn't so I am in a pretty
disgusted place with the Republican
establishment right now and that's the
same establishment that's looking to
lead us to World War III I mean it's
Dick Cheney 2.0 trying to run the
Republican Party except this time they
lose elections consistently and you know
I'm I'm very worried that the same
establishment that has failed the
conservative movement here at home in a
sort of domestic war that they fail to
recognize that we're in I do think it's
a war between those who love this
country and those who hate this country
at home failing to recognize that are
instead making up Foreign Wars to go
fight that don't Advance the American
interest most notably in Ukraine but we
can talk about that more broadly too and
so I'm coming from a place of um you
know I think deep frustration but how
are we going to channel that to
Solutions that's my job not just tonight
but as the next president if we're
elected absolutely and I know that you
have to be prepared for any topic any
question any time of day it seems like
your entire life right now is answering
these questions and being prepared but I
think if anybody's looking to kind of
read the tea leaves the international
questions the the the kind of
geopolitical questions seem like they
would make the most sense tonight is
that the sense that you and your team
are getting as well I mean yeah I think
that's the vibe it makes a lot of sense
I mean I I think think there should
probably be some introspection in the
GOP about why the hell we're repeatedly
failing um you know why we as a country
have lost our own identity at home why
there's the self-loathing we see on
display most recently on college
campuses but you see it the
self-loathing on display in this country
so I think there should be some
discussion of the cultural rotten cancer
at the heart of this country but yes
right now uh more than ever we're at
risk of potentially entering major
conflict in a way that we haven't for
very long long time in this country and
I do think that's also where we have the
deepest divisions within the Republican
party and in the cultural issues we have
different perspectives on how we'd
address it I think that you know I'm
biased when I say this but I think
somebody who has a deeper understanding
of what's going on is going to be better
positioned to address it but those are
nuances but on International matters we
have deep differences on what we should
be doing there are other people in this
party who believe we should be writing
tens of billions and then hundreds of
billions of dollars more checks to
places like you Ukraine I solidly
disagree with that I think it does not
Advance the American interest I would go
so far as to say it's now hurting the
American interest and increasing the
risk of major conflict it's not just the
money some people think we're $34
trillion in national debt and that me
still means we should be giving Aid
packages willy-nilly to people whose
national debt per capita is less than
hours I disagree with that so those are
real you know ideological divisions
within the GOP so it would make sense to
me if we smoked some of that out tonight
um you know last night actually we held
a rally in Miami it was the stop World
War III rally and uh we rolled out my no
to neocon pledge which is basically
three simple things I'm going to ask
anybody who's a political appointee in
my Administration to commit to that they
acknowledge that world avoiding World
War II is a vital National interest that
Nations that the job of every US policy
maker is exclusively to US citizens here
at home and that war should never be a
preference only a necessity so that's
not controversial but at the same time
it runs
directly counter to the neocon worldview
that's dominated our party for much of
the last several decades and so you know
that that we made a little website for
it no to neoc cons. and people can can
see the pledge and we want to give as
many conservatives across this country
to sign up to those basic basic
commitments that I think every person in
our movement should make but that's
different than with some of the other
people on that debate stage some of whom
stand to make money from going to war
personally make money from going to war
yeah you know I think will'll represent
are you going to actively call for the
other candidates tonight to sign that
pledge or be willing to at least commit
to it tonight I think so I mean I I I've
publicly called for that so I think in
the debate stage I think I want to be a
little bit more fluid and not
um you know not scripted um you know I
think
um you know I mean to go through this my
first time going through a political
campaign like this right so you go
through different iterations you learn
in retrospect you know I mean I was
trying to wear
a I would say a team player hat a little
bit say all right maybe we can you know
unit around certain common themes in
that second
debate it just it just wasn't use I mean
second for so many reasons wasn't useful
but I wasn't really particularly useful
I would say you weren't yourself we
talked about it when you were here at
the studio for for the Ash Wednesday
that we did and I said I was I was
yelling at the monitor I was just like
come on this isn't you you know and I
was thinking about I mean you gota you
know I mean I I I wouldn't say cut me
any slack at all because you know I'm a
candidate but I'm telling you as a first
timer going through this you experiment
with different modes and mentalities and
head
spaces and you know today I'll tell you
what my day looked like before the
debate stage I um went for jog this
morning then we went for uh jet skiing
slamming the ocean a little bit I'm G to
go we were in the pool before I'm going
to go back to the pool G to have a meal
with my family and then we'll come back
to the uh to the place we're going to
have the debate and and I just want to
kind of keep it so so maybe I'll mention
mention the not neocon pledge if that
feels like it's not particularly those
three commitments great people have the
website afterwards we're running this
campaign the not neocon pledge through
December 7th that's the date that the US
entered World War I right to have as
many that as December 7th this year to
say that we will make it a priority to
keep us out of World War II but whether
that comes up on the debate stage or not
we'll see I'm going to be pretty fluid
tonight I am um I'll tell you right now
I mean we're a few hours before the
debate I am at a um you're catching me
at an irritated moment at the Republican
establishment broadly it's to cancer I
think that it needs to be cured if the
country is going to be cured and there
needs accountability for you know the
failures of this party and I think that
in many cases it behaves a lot like the
Democratic party except like a less
competent version of it at times and so
you know I think that those those are
some of the themes on my mind and I
think that the risk of World War II and
our entering it potentially major
conflict soon sleep walking our way into
it is a risk that both parties I think
bear responsibility for and I think I'm
going to be the only non- neocon on that
stage tonight calling
for the us to do something other than
intervening in foreign conflicts and
instead focus more on protecting our own
Homeland and our own borders which we're
badly failing to do here at home and
then you know the response I'm sure will
be oh we can walk and chew at the same
time you're doing neither is the answer
that I have to anybody who comes with
that response and so there's some people
on that stage who ideologically believe
it others who and this is ugly but it's
an ugly truth just like the Biden crime
family stand to make money off of
selling off our foreign policy that's
happening in the Republican party as it
is in the Democratic party and so that
deserves to be called out as well and so
I hope we'll get you know I don't know
if we'll get that on the debate stage
tonight or it'll be in the subsequent
months of this campaign but if we're
hitting on Rel topics you can expect me
to be pretty unrestrained and bringing
some of that up well look I think that's
what people like uh that's what people
like about President Trump they they
like that he really doesn't hold back
you know exactly what he thinks it seems
most of the time whether you like it or
not um and I think that's what people
liked about you right that you were
you're very fluid in that second debate
you talked about you know strategy
shifting just a little bit and you know
one thing that you did you kind of
leaned over to me as you were leaving
and said I think you're going to like
what you see in the third debate um when
you were you know after the St I'm
hoping that it's this that that lowgrade
or even you know mild to S genal I'm
just done with the gential Norms um it
doesn't you know you as I said aada go
through different stages I'm a human
being we experimented I experimented you
know with different modes you know I've
never led the Free World before I've LED
companies before but uh you know
thinking about the different ways some
in some way sometime some ways one of
the piece of advice I actually gave to
young person recently is just view
everything as an experiment right I mean
life is an experiment so you you you're
able to learn the most that way and I
think this campaign in some ways has
been uh you know I'll I'll try to follow
my own advice yeah and I think the
experiment that worked best is me being
unrestrained and you know unattached to
a
specific you know political goal but to
say that my whole strategy is speak the
truth and if that's what the people of
this country want their next president
that's what they're going to get in me
and if not then go for somebody else
right I think you have to just be who
you are totally at peace with that
[Music]
yeah you're not the chosen one Gerald
you're terrible and you're gay I'm the
chosen one you see I'm the one who
created my everyone knows that it's
growing no thanks to you Gerald of
course this is all for you this is It's
Your mug it's your Club it's your mug
club I'm behind the scenes guy I I'm I'm
just trying to help you and I'm not gay
I did what our detractors didn't think
was possible and I did it all while
having my name smeared through those
filthy rags with which you wrap your
rotten fish and you know what you know
what I made a deal with Rumble and I
delivered them hundreds of thousands of
mugs day one and now it's our vision my
vision not Gerald's vision and we're
leading the charge and you know what
outside did you know what outside did I
took the good people of Rumble out to
dinner and I did it with your salary on
your dime I paid it cash in hand it was
delicious I had to ve why would you do
that that's a baby cow why why You' let
it grow up and give it false why are you
why are you doing this oh God stop your
gay nonsense you're just the afterbirth
Gerald that slithered out of your
mother's fil no why are you doing this
they should have put your face on a
YouTube PL when they shot it at the
range two for one you think you're great
you think you're so but Gerald where
were you when I was bringing on Nick
dealo where were you I brought on Brian
gon and and the best bit of news Alex
Jones no no no he he can't be got you
couldn't have gotten him I did he can
and he was newest addition to the
network no thanks to you no thanks to
you in your gay face why why I not gay
I've been married for years you know
this
gay
gay Gerald Morgan is what you are you
glorified pool boy so sorry so gay hey
hey if you have a Muk Club okay you have
a Muk Club there it is hold hold it up
there it is you have a Muk club and I
have a m club and I have a
straw there it is see the straw now
watch it
see the
straw and my straw reaches
across the
room and it starts to drink your mug
Club I drink your mug Club I drink it
up wait what the hell does that even
mean I'm finished
remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at lwith c.com
mugclub for $89
[Music]
annually
n
[Music]
oh
wor equ I'm not trying to like be a
provocator I'm just trying to get a real
answer cuz they never give a real
[Music]
answer you'll see the authorities people
who are supposed to look out for you
instead they're running interference for
them 23 years it's a little more severe
than being let out with a $50 bail We
Will Never Surrender our sources we will
never compromise on the truth and our
pursuit of those who live in the shadows
of evil will never ever stop our eyes
and ears are everywhere we are many we
are among you we are we are much
Undercover
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what I
know
strange I got
[Music]
ah this is a disaster hey glad to be
with you uh I have a pinched nerve in my
neck so you'll notice everything has
been moved over because I was having to
pull a trump with a cup of water and
move my hand with my other hand so uh
and I just spilled a bunch of water
kicking it over glad to be with you
working with a stroke
victim that's like Jer L telepon I'm one
of the kids
[Music]
yeah
I know but they you know used to he can
he's alive in your hearts just like
these debate streams these are always
fun and by that I mean they're not but
we make them fun as best we can right
now you can use the hasht Crowder debate
stream or is it Crowder debate night
sorry CR debate night uh we have a
drinking game that you can play along
with tonight bring up the drinking game
rules all right you drink and you'll
hear this anytime someone says I stand
with Israel or Ukraine anytime Chris
Christie acts tough oh Lord anytime
someone say says that uh they can but
Trump can't win a general election uh
anytime there's an Indian cat fight
between VC and Haley or at least a
portion of her I know she was Indian
anytime a candidate mentions their home
state and you have to finish your drink
anytime someone says Biden isn't
running or if the Nashville Manifesto is
uh mentioned which I don't think it will
be I have I have you know some maybe V
will like you know the I'm sorry and
we're going to get into our predictions
what happened last night with the
election but before that look uh there's
still the promo code undercover right
now if you go and join mug club lc.com
mugclub uh because of what happened this
week with the Nashville Manifesto and I
want to clarify a few things there have
been some rumors out there uh look no
Source was paid for this story and our
source is still safe has not been
relieved of Duty or fired just to be
clear those rumors have been circulating
there have been seven officers allegedly
Rel or an administrative Le
ad Metro Nashville police y our source
is fine not one of them could be pennil
because we didn't pay them but fine we
will go to jail to protect our sources
so get these rumors well I just don't
want you know when people go out and
they report irresponsibly it can
intimidate whistleblowers into silence
and we have whistleblowers at the
highest levels of government right now
right so continue to send in your tips
at lwc tips protonmail.com my question
to you as well as what do you think the
topics will be tonight we think it's
going to be foreign policy yeah um and
what do you think is an important topic
that should be but won't be discussed
tonight all right I'm thinking is there
anything else I need to mention oh Alex
Jones will be here for the postgame yeah
post debate wrap up without we debated
having him in this chair but you know
it's like you have to have an you have
to MC this where you have to stretch it
short it and Alex is always a headlining
act like you know I love that Vic put it
that way because uh if I can just for a
minute just discuss this for a minute
it's like you mean 10 minutes and hours
later yeah exactly because he's
brilliant he's brilliant but he's he's
sometimes a solo act he's perfect for
the wrap up where he will catch he gets
a second win at 9:00 in the evening he
said so like oh boy that's going to be
right around the time he gets that win
whatever he comes out of the
manr well I tell you what picked up his
speed and I don't know what's going on
in there there's no cleaner place to go
than Bucky so the man does know how to
pick his rooms wisely and even though
he's dead George Michael will live in
our hearts forever number two in command
CEO Gerald Morgan how are you sir I'm
doing well I'm sorry your neck this is
we were going through kind of run
through to mock up everything and make
sure we're ready to go and you're like I
I can't lift my arm no I know well
that's that's going to be tough and it's
a pinch nerve and I know our sponsor CB
Distillery you know uh to don't Indi
them because I literally have a ruptured
disc in my neck and pinch the nerve like
their stuff is great but it won't you
did rub it on me and then Noom you
rubbed it on me and then Nick rubbed my
neck but it was it wasn't even a request
hold on a second well Nick just walked
in it's my turn he he has strong
Sicilian hands the other one it's two
Nicks here you mean the Al Gore would be
so lucky to have a massuse as handsy as
and is
uh old the love of my sister oh boy g g
Willers uh love of Pete I wasna say for
the love of Pete right know Pete that's
it was Pete we all kill Pete with
kindness so you can watch uh do we have
his intro music I guess I guess do we
have it yeah his show on mug Club you
get it Monday through Thursday at 5:00
p.m. uh Eastern The Funniest Comic alive
the funniest man alive he is the guy who
everyone in the industry says that's the
guy Nick PA how are you sir I'm I'm
traumatic could you play my theme a
little lower Jesus Christ would you hide
me well he just you know cuz you can't
hear cuz you don't have headphones on
yeah it was louder in my ears it's a
good point yeah anyways uh this who who
is right now let's bring this up right
now is this uh that's Romney's uh is
that I was going to say she looks almost
like she's more Botox than human yeah
that's the person who got their butt
kicked last night because they didn't
have great strategy across the country
well what do you expect when you assign
it to walking
botulism okay the Republican president
uh so here what are your predictions
really quickly and Gerald you tell me
what we want to get to again it's
Crowder debate night uh the drinking
games are going to be going on all night
and uh we have some uh what well so
really quickly uh we will be going to
Donald Trump speech his rally in Hala
right that's just down the road I think
it's 10 minutes away um I don't know if
he's actually on stage right now
speaking but just so you know not we'll
be going to it when he does so we'll be
kind of cutting back and forth and also
if there are like epic mic drop moments
from Donald Trump which are typically
are then we'll have those we'll clip
those we'll bring them in you don't have
to go anywhere to watch anything else
we'll have both for you tonight tonight
we'll have some wrap ups so what has
happened since the last debate as well
then our predictions obviously what
you're talking about right now I I think
foreign policy because of everything
that's happened the world is a very
different place than it was when they
had the last debate and you can't walk
into the white house uh in in 2024 and
I'm sorry technically in 2025 you can't
walk in and get anywhere without
understanding what's going on in the
world and having a good plan for keeping
the United States out of a broad War
right World War III or whatever other
conflict prer D War yes so you've got to
be really sharp on this and so I think
right now we're going to see a contrast
between people who want to keep us out
of war and do it reasonably not not like
an isolationist and you'll see some
people who are a little bit more hawkish
so VC versus pretty much everybody on
the stage they'll be they'll be saying
he has no experience he'll be saying you
all want to go to war he was a little
pissed too when he was talking to me he
he's like I'm I'm a little fired up
about how badly We performed last night
and also what we are doing we're
sleepwalking into a war and the
Republicans are not doing a very good
job of handling this what do you think
there Nick well it's going to be a
foreign policy because has us
on the brink of and that's the strategy
not to get it to World War get
out of there it's Commander that word
Commander yes commander and and
we do that not a week from now we do it
tomorrow we'll also allow
and chief there you go we'll go
with either the above we just have we
have to respect the office and I think
they'll be talking about too many flags
in the NFL yeah you know is it breast
cancer awareness monke everyone be
wearing pink no honestly but anyways uh
and VC again that that was my boy but I
think it was Jimmy breu who sent me a
text a couple months ago saying you you
better do homework on your boy I think
it was Brew I'm not sure there was no
name on the but it was Long Island I
don't know did he did he write
out but he said you know and there was a
clip of a using like three no like five
phrases that Obama used when he was
running for president it did make me
scratch my head but wor well bre just is
very mistrusting and that's a good thing
it's a good thing to have someone like
that who question his dealer everyone is
they're a train
sealed um all right so how the hell
sounds about right uh I don't know I
need something for my
neck how about a
hatchet oh don't talk about Nicki Haley
that way now we have it's a wound now
let's uh let's go actually this is a
good time to to I someone help me let's
get out of this and uh recap what
happened since the last debate I believe
we have a montage of kind of what
happened politically uh since the last
debate and then after that we have
what's happened with Donald Trump since
the last debate since he looms over
these people like that's what they
should call him the
Shadow and Donald Trump continuing to
lead overwhelmingly here notably
DeSantis who's been running in second
all year now joined by Nikki Haley in
second place Governor Ron DeSantis is
getting a lot of bad campaign news this
week not only is he losing out on
endorsements he's getting bad poll
numbers he's also taking heat for his
Footwear for you to wear
okay I shop at ferl okay
and I got I don't accept gifts I can't
accept it mean let's face it Donald
Trump is political and electoral poison
down
ballot what a shock you're for Trump I'm
going to fall over dead your arguments
are so great and mine STI a butt at you
a sh quiet this guy reviles Republican V
I hate this guy set you
free what do we cut to a waffle house
isn't it time for people like Tim Scott
to drop out aren't they just wasting
time at this point yeah yeah you want to
tell them that I think I just did
hallelujah oh he doing Tyler Perry now
you're hearing this story do we fund
Israel or do we find
Ukraine no don't get involved in that
she's a child and this is the Tantrum of
a child ignorant Cocker bloodthirsty I
came here to say it's become clear to
me really this is not my
time oh my it'll be your time when
you're
90 that poor bastard you you have been
forgotten so that happened right we had
the debates we had a lot going on I feel
like I know this person right here on
NBC but I don't want that reporter but I
don't want to speak out of turn cuz I I
think I know that person uh I know who
she is
I swear to God she's familiar right yeah
she served us at the IHOP last time I
was here that is and she wouldn't give
me the blueberry syrup I don't want the
current Berry syrup I want the blueberry
syrup uh let's go to Donald Trump what
he has done right since the last debate
this is what we have it's a scam it's a
sham just so you know my financial
statements are phenomenal federal judge
tkin left the bench came back ruled that
Mr Trump cannot make or repost
statements attacking the special counsel
Jack Smith his sta or family or judge
chuin staff this is not my time I chose
him made him president but people people
in politics can be very disloyal I've
never seen anything like it a vote for
president Trump is a vote to secure the
border and it's a vote to keep radical
Islamic terrorist the hell out of our
country or find his way off a stage he
can't find his way off a
stage all numbers are terrible you show
what happened today the New York Times
and CBS came out with a poll that I'm
leading all over the place because it's
a scam and this is a case that should
have never been brought a new CBS News
poll shows that 34% of Republican
primary voters say the legal challenges
he faces make them think better of him
yeah and by the way we're going to go
back to those polls because they have to
change the polls to try and make it seem
like there's any silver lining for Joe
Biden right now I want to before we do
that kind of give you a recap from last
night now look this is something people
are really irresponsible out there where
you have a lot of uh GOP voters who
think that everything is rigged so why
go out and vote a lot of people stayed
home now a lot of people are applying
that to a national election uh but they
really don't add up as a matter of fact
the recent polls from New York Times are
surprising as it relates to a national
election let me kind of give you a recap
of what happened last night and you guys
can comment below hit the like button
because it helps with the algorithm um a
lot of the elections uh that were held
yesterday did they didn't go as well as
people were hoping for I believe do we
have a brief uh let's go to clip
election day but there's some context
here that is missing a little bit and
there are some wins that the media
doesn't want you to know about well
election day 2023 results are in and
Democrats scored big in some key races
notable wins include Ohio which voted to
enshrine abortion rights at the state
level Virginia where Democrats will now
control both the state and Senate and
houses of and House of delegates and in
Kentucky where Democratic governor Andy
Basher has was reelected to a second
term President Biden weighed in on the
victory saying quote americ am an once
again voted to protect their fundamental
freedoms and democracy one he weighed in
with his frail bird
bones uh soent some let me give you the
bad okay so the bad obviously you know
what happened in Ohio with the uh the
abortion protection okay you know that
the Kentucky Governor obviously Democrat
was uh elected there um you probably
know that they won like she just said
both houses of the Virginia state
legislature here's something else that's
pretty interesting in Pennsylvania votes
were being flipped due to a coding error
oops in a judge's race no no no hold on
can't possibly be the the voting
machines could be compromised could
could be just not good hey before we get
into the idea that Chavez is ringing
they just may not be all that good go
and watch killchain on HBO where they
hacked it in governor race but here's
something that you may not know is you
know the abortion when people talk about
it they say oh so it must be a losing
issue period conservatives were outspent
2 to one what happens is after Ro v Wade
was overturned they didn't know what to
do with it and they don't have very
clear messaging here are some wins
though that people may not necessarily
uh know about the Virginia delegate
candidate who by the way who performed a
sex acts on ChatterBait lost so that's a
good thing I think yeah that that's
overlay F5 there uh Matt I know I'm
bouncing all around Republicans gained a
seat in the New York City Council in the
Bronx there you go AOC aoc's from there
and then uh the GOP Now controls all of
Long Island so you know hey think about
it that means the GOP they're probably
gaining with the Jew vote I
was the M that's where I was headed you
beix sorry no I'm sad La up the look we
don't do that they do well with the the
the the schnaz V it's Italian and Jew
yes exactly could be listen what kind of
people are these Henry you do you have a
nice strong Roman nose you do nice
strong Roman I have a Roman nose has a
Roman nose my mom loves that's what she
say like you know what I like in a man I
like a strong Roman nose I like Roman
around my ass really that's my mother oh
you said your mother thought you said
your brother
okay don't make me laugh too hard my
neck hurts it hurts it's I can feel the
bones oscillating uh
the Michigan House of Representatives
it's now evenly divided right so that's
pretty good you have for Michigan you
take that as a win considering that you
know the lady who runs that state her
stocking should roll up under a flying
house we have the uh GOP Governor
Mississippi one versus the distant
cousin of Elvis Presley so that's good
if you're excited about a republican win
in Mississippi it's a bad night
I mean it should happen well you never
know he's still hanging people down
there but this doesn't compute with what
we're seeing with with Donald Trump so
New York Times just had a new poll come
out very different national election and
this comes to the people running the GOP
they're not being ganized uh New York
Times in the general election Donald
Trump beats uh Joe Biden just to be
clear uh by well I don't know if they
have this is New York Times 1.4% in a
national election that's within the
margin of error yeah now this time in in
the 2020 election Biden was winning by
10% in the polls meaning at this point
in time November when you're looking at
that point in the election cycle uh 2016
election had Hillary winning by 2.2 so
that is a huge swing yeah then Donald
Trump is leading in swing state big time
Big Time and and we were surprised by
this to app comparison and by the way
just for everybody watching we got about
a minute and 10 seconds until okay so
let me hit this really quickly Trump is
leading Biden five in uh in the critical
swing States uh Nevada he's leading
Biden Donald Trump by 11% uh we have
them in 2019 Biden was up 3.6% in
Georgia Trump's winning by 6% in uh 2019
the RCP average had Biden up 4% in
Arizona Donald Trump is up 5% the same
New York poll in 2019 had Biden up 3%
Michigan Trump is up five New York Times
in 2019 had Biden up plus one
Pennsylvania Donald Trump is plus4 New
York Times had him in 2019 up uh sorry
down by one to Biden then you have
Wisconsin uh surprisingly Biden is up
two which surprised me compared to
Michigan but if you look at the New York
Times They had him up by two as well so
same time same time at that in this
point in 2019 yeah which surprises me
considering Scott Walker and all of that
so um this is also something if you look
at his polling with black people he's
bringing in 22% of the black vote right
now the most in any modern GOP history
Biden is only leading Donald Trump
according to the New York Times in
recent polls with people under the age
of 30 by single digits by 1% he's only
leading Donald Trump with Hispanics by
8% single digits this is something that
we have never seen before and that's the
difference between a national election
and someone who overcomes that
enthusiasm Gap so we can get back to it
but do we want to watch the intro right
now yeah let's watch the intro let
everybody get into the debate and then
I'll come back can tell you how those
polls even got worse they narrowed
dramatically excited about any what you
descri it's going to be really really
good for Trump based on what we know you
should be excited about it because Roman
another cup considering the the idiot in
office and the shape this country's in
those should be twice that Gap swing all
right but anyways didn't mean to spoil
your whole day like that I don't believe
any of those freaking numbers okay but
let's go to the intro now so we can be
bored with that Trump who's far ahead in
the
polls the candidates are here Florida r
s get Ambassador Nikki Haley
entrepreneur that America's favorite
indan the token
Fator token black guy from NBC News
first Nikky she's cute but she's a
the Center in Miami Florida hold
on her cat fight with with VC over who
more Indian do the cat sound and I'll
give you a little
[Applause]
okay that's what I'll sound
like good evening all right let's watch
them introduce Lester Holt what is that
guy how is NBC involved with this
headline yesterday I'm Christ Welker
moderator of NBC's Meet the Press hello
I'm Hugh hu
host show we are now just 68 days from
the Iowa caucuses when Republican
primary voters to deter their part's
nominee for president tonight we'll
question five candidates seeking that
nomination how they're best prepared to
be commanderin-chief and of course how
look like a cartoon of
lesterol have serious debate on the
issues that matter most to Republican
voters c 1 minute and 30 seconds for
answers and the opportunity for a Clos
use the hash Crowder debate or sorry
it's Crowder GOP debate is what it says
Crowder go they just change it I had
prouder debate night you sons of
you H me out to dry the promo code
undercover if you want to see more of
what we the naville manifesto that's
still the same you get $10 off to join
mug Club hey it's Indian Jimmy looking
down
at the critical issues we're facing like
he was trying to like why isn't she
making sandwiches like he like he was
doing an alucino face Ronda santz he was
sitting may result in loss of additional
questions and to our audience I don't
like NY big ass can be
heard let's have a good debate all right
our first question the open question is
one for all of you Donald Trump is the
first president more than 100 years to
run for the White House again and he
remains popular among Republican primary
voters as his legal challenges Mount
Governor DeSantis let me begin with you
on this one speak to Republican voters
who are supporting Donald Trump why
should you and not him be the Republican
nomin
to face Joe bid lines this country is in
trouble and the elites that have put us
here they don't care about you they
don't care that you're having to Grapple
with higher grocery prices or have
higher gas prices they don't care that
your family's less secure because of the
open border that's allowed drugs and
even terrorists to come into this
country well I care I am not going to
sit idly by and let this country
continue its downward spiral we need
leadership and we need it now I'll take
the hits I'll take the arrows I'll take
the slings because ultimately it's not
about me it's about you I will fight for
you I will make sure to lead this
country's Revival and I will win for you
and your family actions speak louder
than words we don't have time for EXC
your tie speaking pretty loudly that
thing is vibrating like crazy question
get the job I like him but this is an
where we are now it's a lot different
than we were in 2016 and Donald Trump's
a lot different guy than he was 2016 he
owes it to you to be on this stage and
explain why he should get another chance
he should explain why he didn't have
Mexico pay for the border wall he should
explain why he racked up so much debt he
should explain why he didn't drain the
swamp and he said Republicans were going
to get tired of winning well we saw last
night this is the first time we've seen
s come out on this level of attack to
Donald Trump he had a meeting with some
people they said you're not doing very
well this is your last shot you really
need to make your mark I don't think
that this is well advised Miami D County
that's how we have to do it so I promise
you this as the nominee next November
I'll get the job done and as president I
will deliver time is up let me turn to
Ambassador ask right but he
had why you and not the former president
well I think you look at the fact that
we're almost $34 trillion in debt 60% of
americ out of drink 50% of American
families can't afford diapers one
families can't pay their utility bills
you have parents who are worried about
said or Tau to their child in the
classroom there's no transparency we
have anti-Semitism all over our college
campuses and stud transp like when you
look at yourself in a mirror you've got
an open border where terrorists can come
through and we've got someone said let's
give her the let's give her the photo
negative Dracula collar tonight what a
cop president Trump well I can talk
about President Trump I can tell you
that I think he was the right president
at the right time time I the Right
president now I think that he put us8
trillion in debt and our kids are never
going to forgive us for that the fact
that he used to be right on Ukraine and
and foreign issues now he's getting weak
in the knees and trying to be friendly
again I think that we've got to go back
to the fact that we can't we can't live
in other headlines we've got to start
focusing on what's going to make America
strong and proud do you mean like the
greatest economy modern America has ever
seen this is the with attacking Trump I
get that Trump they say Okay lost an
election and we can get into how that
happened and the the chanary of foot but
let's talk about the fact that it was
the greatest economy that we have seen
in modern American history that the
public sector jobs were actually for the
first time in our life Donald Trump
shrunk them by 3,000 we'll have these
numbers side by side with Joe Biden
because they're trying to tout his
latest jobs report which they have to
inflate up how about the fact that there
were no major new Wars this is the
fundamental problem you guys can comment
below and let me know if you disagree in
attacking Donald Trump when people not
even Republican you're looking at right
now the approval among black Americans
Hispanics people under 30 they know they
don't have a leg to stand on if they say
the economy is better off right now
under Biden or that we are better off
with our International relationships
under Biden they know it's not true so
attacking Trump just as ill advised I
want to see what Johnny quest's uh py
here has I think there's something
deeper going on in the Republican party
here and I am upset about what happened
last night deep blue v we become a party
of losers at the end of the day we it
cancer the Republican establishment the
truth I mean since Ronald McDaniel took
over as chairwoman of the RNC in 2017 we
have lost 2018 2020 20122 no red wave
that never came we got trounced last
night in 2023 and I think that we have
to have accountability in our party for
that matter Ron if you want to come on
stage tonight you want to look the GOP
voters in the eye and tell them you
resign I will turn over my yield my time
to you and frankly look the people that
are cheering for losing in the
Republican party this is a race to the
negative love it s is like the country
sucks this President sucks everything
sucks and him he just he's like H we're
all
losers more people into our party you
think the Democrats and we've got Cher
here shining City on a Hill Screw The
Shining city on a hill we suck we suck
but how do you lose I know those are
local races and a lot of how do you
lose well I don't when the condition the
I mean the Dems have had the White House
for four years the country the condition
how do you lose at any level it's the
spending and of course the GOP but I do
want to hear the rest of V talk about
radio check answer the question go
Mr this is how we get our country back
wait what did he say answer the question
can someone send us a mission control we
were having too much fun the 2016
election they rigged the 2020 election
with the hunter Biden laptop story and
they're going to rig this
election why that's a mic Dr moment if
I've ever heard one but I'm not
finishing my drink piss we interviewed
him and hold on let's see let's see what
he say the candidate speak Governor
Christie call on the
election well Lester look well you said
it at the beginning of the debate we are
dealing with
extraordinarily important issues facing
this country right
now have our greatest Ally in the Middle
East Under Fire fromp that has committed
to wiping them and every Jewish person
in this world off the map we have
Ukraine with Vladimir Putin a communist
KGB dictator boring stand with Ukraine
and Israel how boring is he compared to
VI coming out
fation in this country that is choking
choking every American
Family rise up I'm up to the last loop I
have to use a bobby pin to make a new
one tonight we need to decide he won the
governor's trophy in the days to t the
big
issues not just inward but look outward
at the world and say America is the
country the indispensable nation that
makes this a safer world and in a safer
World American innovation American hard
work has always been the thing that has
driven our country to greater things I'm
going to be the president make the world
sa the same the local buffet how is he
still around I
mean don't
understand a good example you wonder how
does the GOP lose the leadership he's
still in because enough people with
money are saying Chris Christie should
still be in anyone out there a Chris
Christie fan I've never met you I
performed thousands of people around
this around the country I've never met a
Chris Christie fan I do want to hear Tim
Scott because I do like him he's like
he's like black tiny here from ET we
need a president and a candidate who
will actually help our base solidify and
attract independent voters into our
party the great opportunity party is now
winning back African-American voters and
Hispanic voters because we are working
on a foundation based on faith our
nation is facing some deep challenges it
is the loss of faith in this nation that
is part of the erosion that we're seeing
every single day it's restoring Faith
restoring our Christian values that will
help this nation
once again become the city on the hill
when Ronald Reagan talked about the city
on the hill he was coming from Matthew 5
when President Lincoln talked about A
House Divided that was Mark our founding
documents speak to the importance now
this may work he is separating himself
with more of a positive messaging it may
work but what when Clinton talked about
The Shining Hill he's coming from room
211 found good night everybody I would
be the president that helps us restore
faith in God there's for him faith in
each other there is absolutely without
that Focus I like him scottone of the
issues the policies matter we have to
get back to being a nation that is in
fact the city on the hill that believes
in each
other for us to fight for that future
Senator Scott thank you we're going to
turn now to the Scott the American
people are
bored we just lost half our
then from Christen and Hugh and Senator
Scott I don't know how this is but I
Lester Holt am blacker than you next
question
to I want to hear the question troops
are fighting inside Gaza City with over
200 hostages Who Remain captive there
and civilian casualties I appreciate
that he included the hostages still
being captive that's a key bit of
information a lot of people Overlook
prime minister Benjamin do at this
moment Governor Des sandz I would be
telling BB finish the job
once and for all with these butchers H
they're terrorist Amen brother man
they're massacring innocent people they
would wipe every Jew off the globe if
they could he cannot live with that why
is it with the Jews they always say
wiping like they never like not
eradication extermination they always
use the wiping term that's got Jews out
doesn't that irritate you like wipe them
off like say something else like they
would kill all the Jews I just don't
they always say wipe Jews you know it's
like exterminate the Armenians you know
Hotel Rwanda was a m it was a massacre
it's like wipe the Jews what's with the
wiping of the Jews I don't okay sorry
has been atrocious uh we had Floridians
that were over there after the attack he
left them stranded they couldn't get
flights out so I scrambled resources in
Florida I sent planes over to Israel and
I brought back over 700 people to safety
and they were complaining about the
drinks not being
I brought back 700 people and
they were fcking with the thermostat the
ENT TI there's too much ice in this I
told you no ice it Waters down to Scotch
St us Florida the bathrooms are filthy
already Deeds we acted and than you
Ambassador haly what would you do was
like a flight from Disney World Mr
Benjamin Netanyahu to do would you
consider she think this is her shot
she's never met a war she didn't like
the first thing I said to him when it
happened was I said finish them finish I
quoted Mortal Combat on this she was
talking about the sandwiches she made
and we have to remember that they have
to one eliminate Hamas two support
Israel with whatever they need whenever
they need it and three make sure we
bring our hostages home we need to be
very cleare eyed to know there would be
no Hamas without Iran there would be no
Hezbollah without Iran there would not
be the houthis without Iran and there
wouldn't be the Iranian militias in
Syria and Iraq that are trying to hear
hit our military men and women if it
hadn't been for Iran and who is funding
Iran right now China is buying oil from
Iran Russia is getting drones and
missiles from Iran and there is an
Unholy Alliance we need to be cleare
eyed the last thing we need to do is to
tell Israel what to do the only a
different direction I think VI's going
to go a different direction but but he
he will clarify that he's not an
isolationist been hit enough for that
but Nikki Haley is saying exactly what
you thought she was going to say what if
I were arguing with her I would call her
out on the number what's the number of
dollars and how many American soldiers
because then she loses specific yes any
daylight between you and the candidates
we just heard in this issue on what you
would tell the Prime Minister here we go
what I would tell the prime minister no
in fact I would go one step further the
founding vision of Israel was based on
the idea that they don't want to depend
on anybody else's sympathy or Direction
in defending themselves so what I would
tell BB is that Israel has the right and
the responsibility to defend itself I
would tell him to smoke those terrorists
on his Southern border and then I'll
tell him as president of the United
States I'll be smoking the terrorists on
our Southern border that's his
responsibility got a new slan for their
Cruise shoes I want to be careful to
making the mistakes from the neocon
establishment of the past corrupt
politicians in both parties spent
trillions killed Millions made billions
for themselves in places like Iraq and
Afghanistan fighting Wars that sent
thousands of our sons and daughters
people my age to die in wars that did
not Advance anyone's interests adding
to our national debt and Joe Biden sold
off our foreign policy Joe Biden's son
Hunter Biden got a $5 million bribe from
Ukraine that's why we're sending $200
billion back to that same country the
fact of the matter is the Republican
party is not that much better you have
the likes of Nikki Haley who stepped
down from her time at the UN bankrupt or
in
debt then she becomes a military
contractor she joins the board of Boeing
and otherwise and is now a
multi-millionaire so I think that that's
wrong when Republicans Do It Or
democrats do the choice be f
do you want Power
Point first or do you want Dick Cheney
and 3in
heels she is she is Nick Chan heels
though that would get her elected no no
no dick CH and heels I think was going
after Rona santis sort he heels too
sorry that would get her elected if she
was a guy in hey hey these were BOGO
buddy These boots were BOGO fine you're
Frugal will be there with you we'll
stand shoulder-to-shoulder there will be
no daylight but Chang the station a
little bit no daylight unless they just
the white balance on your shot America I
would say to President Biden diplomacy
only is a weak strategy appeasement
leads to war from President Obama to
President Biden Obama sent Millions to
Iran frankly President Biden has sent
billions to Iran that is why I've said
that there is blood dripping from the
hands one thing that I'm noticing we're
not seeing tonight as specifics can we
bring up we did this in a a previous
show the amount of money that we are
giving to the Nations collectively who
want to wipe Israel off the face of the
map we not only have Iran we also give
money to Hamas when you talk about I
believe we have in there Libya Yemen
Jordan so bring those up so we can many
many billions to 10 billion dollars to
the countries around them I think three
billion 3 something billion to Israel so
people should be specific with that
because it's easy to get people to your
side if they understand Hey look there
is a less interventionist policy that
would actually be a Net G net gain for
Israel um they're being they're being
very broad tonight they're not being
very specific and that's kind of the
nature of a lot of foreign policy
debates just to be clear because it's
ever changing right these are very very
temporary circumstances so it's they
don't want to be hung on it yeah to
destroy it all right Senator Scott thank
you am I the only one sweating is it hot
in here feel
hot these problems are so big and
serious that the first thing I would say
to to prime minister Netanyahu is pretty
simple America is here no matter what it
is you need at any time to preserve the
state of Israel remember that hamas's
main goal is to get rid of Israel is to
get Israel absolutely off the map now
there are three things I think I would
say to him when he asked for advice the
first I say that is absolutely your
obligation to protect the territorial
Integrity of Israel secondly to make
when
I right to one of those things it
creates greater unrest in the entire
region second you must go in and make
sure that Hamas can never do this again
the fact is that Israel and their
intelligence Community failed they
failed here and they failed the people
of the state of Israel and so we need to
work closely and better together to make
sure one that they're degraded and two
that we know everything that's going on
in inside Gaza Strip when it's going on
so that something like this can't happen
to kill 1,400 individuals again third
failed country was feeding Iran all this
money exactly that we continue to
isolate Iran work with the reasonable
nations in the Middle East the other
Arab Nations who want to partner with
you and make sure that we continue to
exactly what is and I understand the
idea of the enemy of my enemy is my
friend or the friend of my friend is my
friend or whatever it is that Chris want
say look
these people the hill the hills like
white Christies the thing is uh that was
a short story H but uh literary
reference the thing is with Chris
Christie he's talking about what we've
done for a very long time let's buddy up
with these other nations who will then
turn on us hey how about we say we're
done with this part of the world we're
not going to be your enemies but we're
not going to be giving you money I don't
care who it is I don't care if it's
Saudi Arabia I don't care if it's Egypt
because they'll be friendly at one point
in time and then add 5 years and they're
the next superpower so he is
doing what has been done for a very very
long time that that is the GOP
establishment when people refer to
foreign policy that's the problem you
can let me know if you disagree Nikki
Haley saying something likely
oh she got a cheer what you say
she just said I look good in heels say
is I wear heels they're not for a
fashion statement they're for ammunition
what we need to be doing for ammunition
what are you hiding 50 cows in your 5 in
heels our men and women could be Target
Bo everybody's got Dand almost 100 hits
to happen so much Dand they need silson
blue hey
tell talk about Dand and we shouldn't be
doing the tit fortat like what Joe B
done your mouth to go and take out their
infrastructure that they are using to
with so they can never do it again Iran
responds to Str be honest you couldn't
go TI for anyway so punch them hard and
they will back off but what we don't
need have you ever been in a fight to
get back in the Iran deal him giving $6
billion to get five hostages home him
telling n Yahoo now that he needs a
pause or a ceasefire we don't need him
going and sitting there tiptoeing around
a because he thinks they're going to do
something you don't respond to an enemy
and a terrorist with fear you respond
with strength when you do that that's
when the world pays attention and that's
when our stops thank you Governor danis
if I can continue with you just today
the US launched another one of its
limited air strikes against Targets in
Syria this time Iranian linked facility
how how far would you go militarily to
hold Iran accountable well first Matt
thanks for your question and I
appreciate what you've done over the
last month I know it's been very
difficult for the community and
appreciate you guys rallying together in
difficult times uh I actually served in
Iraq back in the day and um we had
al-Qaeda in Iraq you had Shia militias
that were funded by Iran that were
killing hundreds and hundreds of US
troops and as commanderin-chief I am not
going to put our troops in arm's way
unless you're willing to defend them
with everything you have Biden has them
out there they're sitting ducks he's
doing glancing blows that's just
inviting more this this is a good answer
though as far as putting it in an either
or either you go all in to win a war or
you don't I think that's a fair position
to hold I agree and he's a military
guy credibility to pay we are not just
we all like Ronda santz as a governor
he's just he just he comes across like a
little bit of a weener yeah but why is
he seventh over in the latest why is he
I don't understand man I mean it's how
to screw up an election for dummies yes
all right thank you Governor now our
second and final question for Matthew
Brooks of the Republican Jewish
Coalition please
watch Jewish students across the country
are threatened and under attack what do
you say to Jewish students on college
campuses who feel unsafe given the
dramatic rise in anti-Semitism and what
do you to say to University presidents
and college presidents
who have not met the moral Clarity
moment to forcefully condemn this is
going to be difficult make sure you
answer that you protect free speech on
campus and it needs to reach the level
of criminality right because people have
the right to be and support
Palestine this is something they're
going to try and trip you up they're
trying to catch you with an
inconsistency it's sad to see but here's
what history teaches us anti-Semitism is
a symptom of a deeper cancer in a
country in a society that is lost and we
are lost several years ago when I wrote
my first book woke Inc I was talking
about they were chanting death to
America death to white people death to
Christians nobody was waking up back
then now it's even bad now they're
saying death to Israel and worse so it
is wrong but we have to get to the root
cause here now I think it's really
important that we do this through
leadership not censorship leadership
means fill that void with purpose and
meaning dilute this wokeism and
anti-Semitism to irrelevance these kids
they have no idea what the heck they're
even talking about when they're siding
with Hamas over Israel they are fools
but I also want to caution here if we go
the direction of Ronda santis or Nikki
Haley with whom I respectfully disagree
on this issue Pro censorship telling
student groups to disband mark my words
soon they will say if you question a
vaccine and it side effects your biot
terrorist soon they will say that if you
show up at a school I don't know that I
could have framed a better answer this
is a very good answer to this question
my opinion comment if you disagree
insurrectionist terrorist so that's
where this road ends we don't quash this
with censorship because that creates a
worse underbelly we quell it through
leadership by calling it out these
curious to see the response so just
everyone I want to hear their response
because they have an indefensible
position stes of America that restores
our founding values and that has no
place for this kind of anti-Semitic hate
that's where I stand while respecting
our constitution your time is out
Senator Scott let me get you the way in
on what a horrible moderator he just he
just called out to santis and Nikki
Haley and he okay great let's go to Tim
Scott Federal funding is a privilege not
a right number
one number two stand to every student
who've come to our country on a visa to
a college campus your Visa is a
privilege not a right number
three you rip down a poster send back to
their country two three allow students
to right now rip Perry's going Jesus he
can do it mass murder mass murder and
genocide you should lose your federal
funding today period to all the students
on visas who are encouraging Jewish
genocide I would Deport you from those
campuses we have to stand strong it's a
good it sounds good but it's tough to
actually enforce because a lot of them
are saying we don't support genocide
we're we're saying that we're against
genocide because we're against Israel
whereas at least VX was very very clear
it was concrete he made sure to couch it
and anti-Semitism has no place he
supported Israel morally we sat here
when we talked him about it but he said
look we can't go the route of censorship
it has to reach the level of criminality
just people say I hate Jews on campus
hey if they want to deal with their Dean
or Student Activities coordinator fine
if you're actually calling for violence
boom you're gone this is an answer that
isn't really an answer from Tim Scott
and I know that some people won't like
that of course we've been very
consistent in our support of Israel but
I do not like the idea of and you know
what El I like free speech better than I
like not only do I like free speech it
actually helps the argument when people
see the dumb asses out there supporting
Hamas with Palestinian you look at them
and you're like oh these guys are idiots
but if you say stand with Palestine
which we don't you shouldn't be deported
the problem is the left controls the
media they're in all the
instit US he was attacked common cause
with Hamas I'm canceling your visa and
I'm sending you home no questions asked
where you going second oh well just call
hey someone Florida who their kids do
not feel safe even going to University
campus at all outside of the State of
Florida you have Jewish students all the
Jews again at Cooper Union Joe Biden
should have the Department of Justice on
these college campuses and holding the
universities accountable for civil
rights violations when you have you
should not have money going to these
places I already acted in Florida we had
a group students for justice of
Palestine study at the local showing of
cats I was going to say this is what we
are we deactivated lead thee
that to fund Jihad no way and what is
Biden doing not only is he not helping
the Jewish students who are being
persecuted he is launching an initiative
to combat so-called
islamophobia no it's the anti-Semitism
that's spiraling out of control that is
what we have to confront and as
president I can tell you this we are not
going to stand for this on college
campuses any longer all right Governor
thank you let me turn to governor
governor chrisy and considering what he
just said you let a state with a sizable
Muslim population month you know a
six-year-old Palestinian American
Boy
his landlord his mother was also stabbed
more than a dozen times in what has been
charged as a hate crime what do you say
to Muslim Americans who are also feeling
afraid for their safety right now shut
I'm the only one on the stage who's
actually had experience in dealing with
this I was appointed by President Bush
to be the US attorney in New Jersey on
September 10th
2001 and when I took over that job after
the September 11th your fault I had to
deal with a situation in our state that
was explo
we're the most ethically
divers and so first we heard incredible
reports about Jewish students and
synagogues being threatened in our state
in the aftermath of
9/11 we made sure that we sent federal
agents to those synagogues and we
protected them and the same thing should
be being done now at the very same time
I personally went from mosque to mosque
in went from a size 14 to 19 the leaders
of those mosques and with the members of
the mosques and I said to them law
enforcement is on your side to protect
you regardless of your religion if you
are going to comply with the law and we
developed fabulous relationships with
Muslim Americans all across the state of
New Jersey and we stopped any hate
crimes that were going on either against
Jewish Americans in New Jersey or Muslim
Americans in New Jersey it takes
leadership Lester to know how to do this
you must work with both sides both sides
need to know it but let us never have a
false moral equivalence between Hamas
and Hezbollah and the Jewish people the
Jewish people stand for right and
Justice and Hamas and Hezbollah stand
for death Chrissy thank
you what
you definitely a toughy
moment bring back up the drinking game
rules for people who haven't seen them
yet think you know you look at the the
country and the country is all out of
sorts I think look at what these kids
are with college campuses what makes me
so angry is not only do you have the
kids barricaded in the library they've
said they were going to shoot up the
kosher dining hall you've got kids dorm
rooms who are being set on fire because
they have something related to Israel on
their doors no person should ever feel
in danger like this and this is what I
would say about our College presidents
is if the KKK were doing this every
College president would be up in Arms
This is no different you should treat it
exactly the same anti-Semitism is just
as awful as racism and we've got to make
sure they're protected and for everybody
that's protesting on these college
campuses in favor of Hamas let me remind
you something Hamas said death to Israel
and death to America they hate and would
kill you too and the idea that they're
talking about I get it you're right but
you're not answering the qu we're
talking about campus here we're talking
about it's not us we're better than that
we don't need to celebrate terrorist we
don't need to celebrate genocide we
don't need to celebrate violence towards
anybody Cate a Labor Day with that white
outfit and remember what we are about
and we are about taking care of P suit
appla just no white no white after Labor
Day terrorist activity says they want
see somebody hit her with a glass
of ler thank you a full bottle for the
entire you will all get a chance to
respond but Senator Scott I'd like to
start with you nice teeth Press
host by the way we have a 7 plus1 later
7 plus one things the GOP candidates are
doing after this debate and we do have
our on the ground correspondent Thomas
finan at the debate tonight we will
check in with him I for the United
States and Americans would be forced to
quote send your sons and daughters to
defend NATO countries Senator Scott
where do you stand on more funding for
Ukraine I certainly have been very
supportive of Ukraine I believe that
ultimately we should make sure that the
president United States states what is
America's national vital interest in
Ukraine it is actually integrating the
Russian military we've been very
effective using our resources and our
you can make that argument for any War
then you can make that argument for any
War and the Russian military degraded
themselves and they're sitting on a
stock pile that could blow the world
that degrade the military all you want
of the Russian military and that's good
news but the American people are
frustrated that they do not have a
president who reminds us and tells us
where's the account of ility where are
those dollars how are those dollars
being spent hold on hold on hold on
nobody's asking for receipts Tim
everybody's saying we're sending too
much money overseas to a war that does
not impact us while we have problems
here at home and we're not gearing up
for some of the problems that could
happen I don't know in Israel that was
something that probably could pop off at
any second China and Taiwan that's the
problem nobody's saying hey are they
spending those on M16s or not that why
why are you even bringing that up so
that we show the world that we are 100%
undeniable believe standing shoulder
toosh shoulder with Israel and then as
we turn away from that direct
support should go to our Southern border
and close our Southern border with the
resources necessary I believe that we
have sleeper terrorist cells in America
thousands of people you must be a
detective there Tim Syria and Iraq if we
going about 20 minutes to go here at our
sleep in Chris Christie's FAA hey hey
speak hey Tim Scott how many how many
border walls worth of money have we sent
to Ukraine so far I'm starting to price
things in Border walls so just just help
me out 20 billion by the way bring up
$20 billion for a border wall the most
generous estimate was $30 billion ever
it really cost likely $18 billion and
how much have we committed out to
Ukraine it's over 100 million right now
over 100 billion is billion or is it
eight it's over five fiveish border
walls five border walls not only that
the military's been degraded 10 times
since Biden got office and now we got
another water so I know it's like he
spat in their mouth yes our NATO
Partners safe from the Russian military
is absolutely essential as you
understand Article 5 would require to
support and to defend NATO our troops in
the ground Ukraine is not a NATO country
and by the way look Putin's an
right Putin bad just like Hitler bad
just to be clear however one of the
promises was that Ukraine would never
become a NATO country so for you to act
as though there is no reason that he and
not any reason that you believe in that
he can sell his people as a reason for
continuing a war does not do you any
favors Ukraine is not a NATO country we
pay into NATO more than any other Nation
we always have other people don't foot
their own bill and it was promised to
Russia that Ukraine would never be a
NATO country if you're not addressing
that you're not addressing the root
issue and it's going to be never ending
War which is probably great for the
boards that Nikki Haley's on let me hear
VC sorry cautious as they should level
with the American people here Ukraine is
not a paragon of democracy this is a
country that has banned 11 opposition
parties it has Consolidated all media
into one state TV Med that's not
Democratic it is threatened not to hold
elections this year unless the US Forks
Over more money that is not Democratic
it has celebrated a Nazi in its ranks
the comedian in cargo pants a man called
zalinski doing it in their own ranks
that is not Democratic more facts for
you that you won't hear from the
mainstream media a great night the
regions of Ukraine that are occupied by
Russia right now they all going to
attack him as no foreign policy
experience after this watch Russi
regions that have not
of Ukraine since 2014 that other people
probably couldn't name those provinces
for you those are the hard facts and so
to frame this as some kind of battle
between good versus evil don't buy it
and I'd like the likes of the the
sharpest of the warhawks on Ukraine
Nikki Haley to have some accountability
and answer do you want to use us tax
really going after Nikki haly she's wide
open in this convers actually What's
happen how she got to off using the ukan
Orthodox Church they have banned them
the Ukrainian parli just did this we
supported by our dollars and I think you
owe it to the American people Nikki to
at least this
one of
Christian Mr ramaswami thank you we ask
the questions
Ambassador questions no no no I'm sorry
your your writers write the questions
for you to ask your okay let's hear
Nikki Haley and president she are
salivating at the thought that someone
like that could become president they
would love to the fact of the matter is
she yeah because I'm sure the whole
Middle Eastern Arabic world would
respect you as commander-in
Chief look look at they elect a
woman the first thing I'll tell you is
we all remember
what when he invaded
Ukraine hold on I do want to hear what
stupid stuff she say because of Putin
and here is a freedom loving
pro-american country that is fighting
for its survival and its democracy no I
don't think we should give them cash I
think we we should give them the
equipment and the ammunition to win and
I'll tell you if Biden had done it when
they first so like so like fed it's like
USA fed bucks wait it's like Toys R Us
in the '90s I just want to give them
Jeffrey dollars what the is that
with a t of how how would you pay for
the ammunition and H don't ask questions
funny money from the Gold Club in
Atlanta second now everybody wants to
move away from Ukraine they'll want to
move away from Israel a year from now
America can not at all the same thing we
don't be friends after 911 we needed a
lot of friends now is the time to get
Partnerships this Unholy all alliance
between Russia Ukraine and China is real
there is a reason that Taiwanese want us
to support China Russia has been pushed
into the arms of China because of this
they were not allies before they're
getting friendlier because of our money
to Ukraine now you may agree that having
a war that a proxy war that's fought
there is better than it impacting us
globally I understand that argument I
don't agree with it Russia China very
cold relationship it's it's warmed up as
a result of this that is a fact we
called it when we discussed this over a
year ago on the show and here we are
let's hear The Token fat guy it bought
us just a couple of years and then
500,000 Americans your life expect to
defeat Hitler this is not a choice is
not Hitler this is the price we pay for
being the leaders of the Free World and
the fact is this Alliance is not just
with Russia and
China Governor Haley knows this Iran
Iran is in the middle of this as well
and so is North Korea and they are all
working to support Russia right now and
the reason they're doing it is because
dictators work together the camera is
Orting people who believe in democracy
work together we must stand with all of
those that are standing up for democracy
and freedom in this world and by the way
let's all aging faster because of his
grav a guy a unicycle the handheld it's
like M night shamalan with the island I
need a Dr
they invade you we will protect you an
American promise that's 31 years old is
no different than American promise
that's made tonight on this stage we
need to stand by it and those of us who
forget history are doomed to repeat Slim
Fast challenge make that promise like to
respond and the absolute the absolute
giving in to dictators which is being
suggested on this stage just shows the
immaturity of the
approach I told you they were going to
attack his foreign policy experience he
gave a better answer than they did
regardless of you know who else did
Donald Trump that's right or if Putin is
not stopped now well any suggestion by
zalinsky or anyone else that we should
that we're going to eventually have US
troops there I can tell the American
people when I'm president that will not
happen we are not going to send your
sons and daughters to Ukraine I am going
to send troops to our Southern border if
you look at the threats that we Face
terrorists have come in through ourn
years shut it down I'm going to have the
military and I'm going to deport supp
the people who've come particularly
under Biden who've come from the Middle
East come from all these places now
Biden wants $105 billion UH 60 most of
that's Ukraine including some of it
going to pay pensions for bureaucrats
and salaries that is a totally
ridiculous use of American tax dollars
he says he has money for border to try
to do the media repeat that when you
look at it what most of the money is is
money to process more illegal aliens
into this country how is that solving
the problem that's making the problem
worse and what does he do for the
indopacific a pittance that is the top
threat that we Face we need to bring
this war to an end we need the Europeans
to step up and do their fair share and
we need to get serious about the top
threat that this country faces which is
the Chinese Communist Party he sounds a
lot like Trump sounds a lot like Trump
but you know what it's a valid answer
absolutely I will take it VC and uh and
and DeSantis right now Mr Mr boo boots
China and I let's put a out there who
you I would say santis and V Beijing to
hear you many Republicans believe that
the Chinese Communist party in general
secretary X is an existential threat to
the United States the flash point is
Taiwan for decades and decades the
American Military but primarily the
United States Navy put the camera on
Andy attack from China to the Island
state of Taiwan but Ronald Reagan's Navy
of 600 chips is gone now the question to
you is I'll start because
cabinet his goal was a 355 ship Navy
that's what he pushed for he got to 300
it's now at
291 is that big enough to deter and if
necessary defeat an invasion of Taiwan
that's what she said China has the
largest naval fleet in the world they
Queen what do you got they'll have 400
ships in two years we won't even have
350 ships in two decades China has built
up their military it's not just Land Air
and sea they're doing cyber they're
doing artificial intell IG they're doing
space mushrooms German shepher we need
to do everything we can the first thing
is you go you make sure you have the
back of let's get Nick a fresh drink
from out there he just makeshift at it
like he macgyvered his drink I'm sure
it's terrible China the second thing is
we go to China and we start being tough
on them no more sales of our American
soil to China and let's take back what
that being said it would be hilarious to
see her Tower over XI Shing ping and
just emasculate him there's something
funny about a woman towering over you be
funny too if they cut to Chrissy right
now he had a napkin tucked in head
eating a big
yeah lobster kep sauce in his
hair and then we modernize our military
when we strengthen our military when we
modernize it with the focus ofal
intelligence and space when we make sure
that we have the backs of our friends
whether it's in Israel whether it's in
Ukraine and we should be arming Taiwan
make sure they have the equipment they
need this will be interesting to see if
the comes out and they ask him about
Taiwan because it gave a very good
answer when we did an Ash Wednesday
where he said the level of defense that
we have for Taiwan right now which is
basically um sort of military ambiguity
that would be the lowest I would go I
would elevate it until we become uh you
know we achieve semiconductor chip
Independence and then it would go back
to where it is now and that was
misrepresented in the media you may not
agree with it but I'm curious to see if
he answers this to back up a strategy of
denial of President G's Ambitions and if
China's able to be the world's leading
superpower that will affect you and your
family in ways that are going to be very
bad they will export authoritarianism
all around the world as the cost of
doing business they w't post things like
social credit scores and internet
monitor this is to this generation what
the Soviet Union a stray dog I've
already released a plan we're going to
get to 355 ships at the end of the first
term 385 ships at the end of the second
term the world supply of broccoli and
chicken what they got to 20 years I
think the future of freedom is going to
be determined in
everything will be dripping with
MSG and fighting them here at home with
their cultural you know Ambassador Haley
said somehow I wasn't doing she welcomed
them into South Carolina gave them land
near a military base wrote the Chinese
Ambassador a love letter saying what a
great friend they were that was like
their number one way to to do economic
development in Florida I banned China
from buying land in this state and we
out by the way that's a that's a take a
drink that's a m moment because that is
a great thing for this country we give
everyone everyone a tough time because
it's you know we're children I hope you
appreciate it we also fact check them
any fact checks that need to come back
and we'll do correctly but every time
you ban China no l uh you know massuse
is for six bucks and he's mentioned his
own State we have to drink on that one
okay I need to have mine
refesh well two major problems with the
with the question number one uh we do
not have currently a defense Industrial
Bank to allow us to have the kind of
production that we need in order to keep
a America safe frankly if we are not
prepared to fight and engage in three
continents at the same time think about
where we are today in the Middle East we
are in the midst of trying to back our
strongest Ally in Eastern Europe we'
seeing our resources and our Weaponry
help degrade the Russian military the
indo-pacific we have real challenges the
long-term threat the long-term threat is
China immediate threat is our Southern
Border in order for us to have the
military to fight three different con
continents at the exact same time we are
going to have to invest heavily in our
military but we're also going to have to
invest heavily in an industrial base so
that we can hit our objectives from a
military perspective not only with our
ships but also with our air with our
planes we are so old as a military that
in order for us to re-calibrate we're
going to have to invest one of the
things I do in
my
yeah exactly he's me new jobs by having
high-tech manufacturing come back to
America decoupling from China so that we
focus our attention on creating that
Industrial Revolution that I like him
Scott he's not capable of answering a
question he's not presidential material
very nice guy time to step aside I think
I heard somebody pass out and bang their
head on what would where would you build
it when would they be in the water how
big would the fleet I don't know first
answer is the toxic dest to for people
who don't know about that we're
decommissioning ships in the South China
Sea the foundation of war is economics
rebuild our defense industrial base at
home but here's the Dirty Little Secret
our actual defense industrial base
depends on China for the supply chain
for the F-35 jets for the ships that
we're building think about this why are
we stockpiling that if it isn't to
actually be strong against our enemy
China we depend on them for that just
like we depend on them for
pharmaceuticals just like like we depend
on them for semiconductors so here's why
we can't get tough with China it's
because we depend on them for our modern
way of life and we have to declare
economic independence from our enemy
that's the Declaration of Independence
that Thomas Jefferson at the age of 33
would have signed and today if you were
alive that's the Declaration of
Independence that I will sign as the
next pres I do have to recognize that
Ron s was correct about acknowledging
Nikki Haley's tough talk when she was
ambassador to the calling China our
great friend PCP to South Carolina what
he left out though R and be honest about
it there was a lobbying based exemption
in that bill that allowed s changed his
face someone said give them The Good The
Bad and The DeSantis face I'm serious
yeah he's changed his expression they
said you need to look more tough we need
politicians who are independent of the
forces that increase our dependence on
China my message to xiin Ping is this
you are done buying land in this country
you will not donate to universities in
this country us businesses won't expand
into the Chinese market until you play
by the same
kicked out of the Shut by the way you
know what none of this none of this
tonight this conversation about China
takes place without Donald Trump for
decades we were told in this country it
was inevitability China is going to be
the next great superpower Donald Trump
changed that look at these answers if
you don't appreciate anything else about
Donald Trump the fact that people now
are able to acknowledge the threat that
China presents is something we all have
to agree on I I can't tell you how many
relatives friends I had in finance going
accept it everything's going to have to
learn you better start learning some
Mandarin yeah exactly invest program 20%
I wasted all my time I learned Canton e
you know my first observation to you is
that nobody answers your question and my
second observation is three in the
middle think they're the enemy I know
China is the enemy and that's what we
should be focused on so let's be really
clear the nuclear sub in this United
States Navy is the greatest deterrent to
Chinese aggression and that is the first
place I would go to increase American
Naval power our nuclear submarines are
able to move stealthly quietly and
effectively and if we are going to deter
China from invading Taiwan the only way
we're going to do it is to make sure
that they don't a cannonball off of a
carrier ship and create a Title
Wave China
inami he is a battleship to move on
Taiwan off a carrier shiple program q
and
we that would be priority number one
ships would come next but to me the
ships are secondary Choice here the the
submarines are the single most important
thing that we could be deterring that we
could be
us Jersey sub China is to let them know
that the blood money they're spending
for Russia in Ukraine right now will not
be
affected home with his tail between his
legs and make them understand that the
same fate waits for them if they decide
to move towards Taiwan with a more
aggressive we'll be able to make that
threat real thank you Governor we're
going to take a really quickly here so
Chinese public opinion kind of to your
point has actually turned very uh
sharply towards the United States
recently right so you're saying they
were going to be in favor of the Chinese
public opinion we talk about the CCP and
the Chinese people two different things
yeah Chinese people not so much a fan of
their authoritarian government here but
this may be a good time for us to uh
they've taken a break here we can maybe
maybe see if we can get in touch with uh
f yeah check and see with our on the
ground correspondent I don't I know that
we've sent him out there we'll see how
this and we spare no expense you can use
the promo code undercover because you
know we broke the Nashville Manifesto
here this week and we also have uh Eyes
On The Ground everywhere it's time to go
to our on the ground correspondent
Thomas
[Music]
finnean all right Mr finigan this is the
third debate pretty much know what to
expect but uh what do you what do you
have for us here today St hi
yeah I'm in my car outside the venue uh
I'm ready to go in and I'll check back
in with you later the GOP debate yeah
tonight in Miami you're 100% sure
tonight that you are in Miami at the
right location yes the right City this
this is the first I don't know what to
say I guess um yeah we'll check in with
you we'll check in with you also wanted
to say that okay you know what that's
check
I am positively shocked but I'm glad
we'll check back in with finigan on the
ground we can bring back up the drinking
game rules really quickly I'm going to
have to go get some of this uh CB
Distillery rub them this is what's
keeping me alive tonight and afloat I'm
not I have a pinch nerve but this really
has helped uh CB Distillery you can go
is it the promo code is it Crowder
Crowder for 20% off Crowder for 20% off
all the science the research is there it
does help also their oil is great I just
can't take it before the show because it
makes me a little bit drowsy uh
everything is lab test and they have the
balls to sponsor this show we're about
to go to a commercial break what Gerald
well so we're we're actually we're
actually not going to go to a commercial
break we're going to go to vivc we have
a little bit more about him talking
about Nashville uh and I think people
are really going to want to see his
opinion on the Nashville is this from
tonight this is from my interview with
him earlier today okay we're going to go
to V and then and keep in the bottom the
lower third of course always the debate
so people know I will be right back
Trump up there yeah let's put Donald
Trump up there just switch back and
forth so people know we're covering all
of it is Crowder GOP debate we will be
back I'm going to rub some of this on my
neck and hopefully gain function back of
my right hand okay see you
[Music]
soon we we actually made some news this
week uh and it's funny a late night
comedy show is breaking news around the
around the country I saw that you
interacted with it but we released the
Nashville Shooters Manifesto and I saw
that you you said something and I
actually quoted you on air because I had
seen your Tweet and said that you know
we can handle the truth why go go into
just a little bit of detail why did you
support the release of that
Manifesto not only did I support the
release of it I me I went to Nashville
in August in early August because I
heard the state legislature was
convening a special the governor
Republican Governor by the way was
convening a special session of the
legislature in late August to
anti-un
meas without having released that
Manifesto so that irritated the hell out
of me says I'm going to show up in
Nashville we held a a sort of protest
rally type event and I called for its
release because the reason people don't
trust the government is that the
government doesn't one of the reasons
certainly is that the government doesn't
trust the people with the truth right
trust is a two-way relationship and so
we don't we lack total trust in our
institutions in part because those
institutions do not trust the people who
they're supposed to serve so the ideas
here are a noble lie that the people
can't handle whatever is in there in my
view is whether it's the origin of Co
where it's the hunb laptop story whether
it's the Trump Russia collusion hoax
whether it's the basis for the 2008
bailouts whether it's how many federal
officials were in the field on January
6th whether it's Saudi Arabia's
involvement or intelligence operative
involvement in knowledge of 911 whatever
it is just tell us the truth I mean even
the knowledge about I know it's it's a
sort of a go topic but even UFOs like
what do we know just I mean it's clear
that the government has prioritized this
topic at a far greater extent than it's
public so I just go straight down the
list on any of those topics just tell us
the truth and we the people can handle
it and it's like the Jack Nicholson
scene at the end of that movie right you
can't handle the truth say no no we can
handle the truth and my view is give it
to us not just when it's easy but when
it's hard so when I went to Nashville it
was something really interesting
happened the entire Community there
there were there people who came up and
said no we've talked to the people who
have seen it and it's not what you think
I was like how do you know what I think
all I'm saying is I want it seen there
like no no no no because you think it's
a transgender shooter it's not what you
think and and there's there's stuff in
there that would be very harmful at
least so you know I mean I'm a thinking
person I I like to think and wonder okay
how can we are there some what what do I
know that I don't know can this be
handled through redaction right that's
typically how that's done if there's
like a manual for how to commit a future
attack right I you know I don't think
that there's a public interest in seeing
the howto manual but the question is the
public at least knows
that the police and everybody else has
entrusted them to say okay these were
the motives of the Killer and at least
we know that tragedy happened in
airplane
crashes you can recover the Black Box no
matter what it says deserve to see
what's in there what struck me and I'm
so grateful to you guys for recovering
it and putting it
out is that the kind of stuff they
insinuated to me that would be in there
why this couldn't be released that
wasn't in there at all it was just
political cover all the way down yeah
which shows how rotten our institutional
leaders really are in this case you got
it's not just one institution you got
local police you got the governor you
got the state government you got the FBI
all in on this yeah and it's pathetic
it's an indictment of where we are as a
country and so the same broad
establishment spanning media to to our
own agencies to Our Own federal police
state from January 6th to hun Biden
laptop story 50 CIA intelligence
operatives claiming it Russian in in
intelligence or Russian
disinformation to the origin of coid 19
to now the Nashville transgender shooter
Manifesto we need to restore a culture
of Truth yeah in the United States of
America give it to us not just when it's
easy but when it's hard and so anyway
I'm glad you guys did it and this has
been a big theme for me since earlier
this year and in some ways it was in
some way I was grateful in some ways I
was just upset when I saw it because I
was waiting for where was that
vague to be avoided topic mhm
that might hurt someone or create a
clear and present danger for future
violence it wasn't in there no it was a
lie yeah it was it was all a lie and and
look we we know that there are more
documents there's more information that
could be released this is only a part of
what um was obtained by the police but
were you surprised at the response
released this well no they they could
have very easily released this given us
some information were you surprised by
the response immediately Google started
the the search had like a blacked out
thing saying hey the all right so look
we will get to the rest of we know the
debate is back here you'll have to wait
just a minute to hear his answer to my
question about if he was surprised by
what happened to our coverage but let's
go back to the debate right now on
Governor Ronda Sanz the parent they're
probably Tik Tok apps on half the phones
in this aor talk I'm going to speak to
the fact that two people hit me and you
didn't let me respond so let's first
talk about the fact that they want to
talk about the Chinese land from 10
years ago yes I brought a fiberglass
company 10 years
ago fiberg you are the chair of your
Economic Development agency that as of
last week said Florida is the ideal
place for Chinese businesses not only
that you have a company that is
manufacturer of Chinese military smirk
right now he's like this two
training sites two of your
airports have another company that's
expanding and they were just invaded by
the Department of Homeland Security so
mine was 10 years ago he got the goods
on her I didn't give him anything what's
your story and I abolish that agency
that she's talking about Enterprise
Florida we abolished it and of course we
Bann China from buying land not exactly
a great recruiting pitch if you're
Banning them from
purchasing you know what I'll take it
it's a cat fight between D santis and
Nikki haly
drink W how do you get Tik Tock banned
if you use it well I I I want to laugh
why Nikki Haley didn't answer your
question which is about looking at
families in the eye in the bring the
drink game rules really quickly while
keep the lower third was actually using
for a long time so you might want to
take care of your
family the next generation of Americans
are using it and that's actually the
point you have her supporters crapping
her up that's fine here's the truth can
someone let us know why they're booing
him really quickly to say that we're
just going to ban one app we got to go
further we have to ban any us company
actually transferring us data to the
Chinese here's a story most people don't
great answer because this guy was
anti-censorship before he's making it
clear that's a national security issue
Banning a foreign government from using
Americans private information you people
who think you're going to catch
conservatives well you're Pro free
speech until we get it you get some
views on Tik Tok with your gender bender
this is a good answer and it's
consistent you can't be Fairweather fans
of the right policy get to the root
cause even us companies ins silic Valley
are regularly doing it cut the virtue
signaling the fact of the matter is
Democrats are on Tik Tok today the only
person one of the few people who is
putting up content the way the actual
algorithms work speaking for pro-israel
views or others is more Republicans will
join it but stop us companies from what
he said was about her daughter and I
think she said something to the effect
of leave my daughter out of it and I
think there was some booze because he
had mentioned her and I think he said my
point was the next generation is using
this if we don't speak to them in some
place she still has that feminist in her
so she has to feain offense don't insult
my daughter against North Korea in a
generation we are the that is literally
the reason North Korea stopped testing
ballistic missiles so I said China did
good on their part that was a
negotiation you could never what you
said Nikki those are your words not mine
and so just own up to it
never don't lie to the people about
you my
entire United Nation every day I fought
China and I did look at the no one could
get any agency heads in un I did it by
making sure that we called them out on
human rights I did it by making sure
that we held them accountable on
everything that they did that's the
reason we got out of the Human Rights
Council that's the reason we called them
out and I have there's nothing to say I
Haven exp made afterwards everybody else
is hanging on the R I think that weren't
another by the way ding drink that's
been the deadliest rule of tonight's
drinking game as far as alcohol
poisoning we thought there'd be some but
I didn't know it would be entirely a cat
fight Ambi
on heed outside of his Podium it's like
hey there's a mic president Trump he
tried to ban Tik Tock twice but was
struck down by our federal cour if you
cannot ban Tik Tok you should eliminate
the Chinese presence on the app period
we also should provide in my parents
Bill of Rights we give parents the
opportunity to give their kids
permission under 14 to be on those apps
I think it's incredibly important for us
as Americans to take back control of the
information especially of our kids
exactly good luck his Solutions just
aren't very uh implementable that's his
problem we get to know that almost seems
a little myopic it it seems like he's
kind of he thinks he's Ronald Reagan
speaking to people in the 80s who aren't
aware of how technology Works comment
below if if if you if you think so or
use the hashtag creder debate night cred
is it creder GOP debate they the wrong
one we have to make sure that we use the
tools that are in our tool F China from
buying Farmland near our B knows all
about tools there's a power tool could
chip a tooth they stop stealing our
intellectual property they're literally
stealing our IP to compete against us my
Administration safe one and we start
making sure us to the Chinese I used to
steal their intellectual property during
a test you know I mean so yes
we all did we all did thank you so
much where Millions have fled political
and economic turmoil many Venezuelan
immigrants are settling right here in
Florida former president Trump and
President Biden have taken different
approaches to Nicolas maduro's regime
with little result former president
Trump put economic pressure on Venezuela
and backed one of maduro's Rivals
President Biden temporarily eased
sanctions to encourage
electoral govern ber Sanders raise their
breadlines situation in Venezuela as a
threat to the United States and what
would your approach be we should never
you guys bring up remember bring up that
old Bernie clip people don't realize he
praised the bread lines that's not a
joke yeah what did he say I remember
that's a good thing they're waiting for
the bread waiting for the bread that's a
good thing they said are you sure about
these oh son of a stop cutting me
off when I answer about
Chavez we're going cost but we're also
going to be more energy independent and
secure we'll choose Midland over Moscow
we'll choose the marcelis over the mulas
and we'll choose bakan over Beijing that
is good for America's national security
Biden's green new deal that's good for
Venezuela it's good for Russia it's good
for Iran and it's good for China so I
would turn the screws on the Venezuelan
regime I think it's a corrupt
dictatorial regime and we should never
go hat in hand begging for oil from them
just to be clear would
the sanctions yes absolutely Ambassador
would your approach be you know I stood
on the salmon Boulevard bridge and watch
thousands of Venezuelans cross in the
for hours in the hot sun holding their
babies to get the one meal they might
get that day going from Venezuela to
Colombia they were fleeing socialism and
begging for Freedom we need to make sure
that we do everything we can to sanction
Maduro we shouldn't be getting dirty oil
and Biden just gave 500,000 Venezuelans
temporary get oil I believe from or gas
from 7eleven unless they changed it it
CS me up largely Venezuelan oil a long
time I can't remember it was 711 and
sitgo or they swapped at one point but
7-Eleven a lot of their uh a lot of
their pumps were getting oil from
Venezuela we don't need oil from anyone
else we don't need gas from we do not
need petroleum products from anywhere
outside the United States that is a huge
failure of American policy a lot of it's
a huge failure of the Biden
administration of American policy period
Barack Obama same thing with George W
bush there is no reason that we should
not be drilling for in Alaska no for the
first time under Donald Trump we were a
net oil exporter that was the first time
it happened in our life the last time
you heard tracking no I know huh not
since he killed the Keystone Pipeline
sorry Keystone ex sit on we're sitting
on a kind of right so they go it's bad
for the environment so let's get it from
Venezuela issues for voters that of
course is the economy this is a question
that will go to all of you an Iowa voter
recently told NBC News how am I going to
make sure my Pantry stock without
breaking the bank really quickly I think
this is probably a good time to go to it
Donald Trump talking about I said look
what's the top clip so far from Donald
Trump and I think it has to do him
slugging a lady in the ha do you have do
you have that let's do it all right
let's go bring up the Donald Trump clip
up the radical left Democrats Rigg the
presidential election of 2020 and we're
not going to allow them to rig the
presidential
election
[Music]
n
that's what we say up here in heaven
didn't mention Fred his brother up there
that's and and you know that Nick they
they also called me from hell they said
Nikki Haley's knocking at the gate she's
trying to sell her
body cheap Nikki Haley is what I
think in high
heels build here don't borrow from China
plan that is embedded the made in
America strategy creates 10 million new
jobs somebody three different areas one
is tamam that Obama it up for all
black guys and by the way we're talking
about this economy thing people they try
and change the job numbers we can bring
these up as overlays here uh they just
had a new jobs report from uh Biden okay
so look I understand that you might look
at a number for example unemployment 3.9
thinks think that's great you're not
taking into account under Biden because
you are living obviously the economy and
you know that you are worse off most
Americans know that they are worse off
here's how you know that's true when
even NBC is asking the question
predicated on the premise that okay
people are struggling economically so
how are you going to improve it that was
not the question when they were asking
these questions for the debate between
Joe Biden and Donald Trump they were
asking about Co and how they were going
to bring back the economy they would not
have had that question to ask so 3.9
doesn't seem that bad until you take
into account the labor force
participation rate how many people are
working one two three part-time jobs and
when you also look at the difference
between the public sector versus private
job growth there's something called
shovel ready jobs Barack Obama used that
we've used the example of the Trees in
Northern Michigan where they just said
grab a plant some trees and they were
planted so close together because these
people had no business planting trees
that we call them UPN North trees as you
get toward people know Travers City L
Peninsula it looks like the Mario level
with the mushroom caps yeah because they
didn't know how to plant trees but that
counted as a job so the most striking
difference to me is if you look at the
public sector job growth okay well let's
go to private sector first under Donald
Trump when we compare quarters for
quarters on the jobs report he added
128,000 jobs in the private sector Biden
added 999,000 jobs okay and 96 of those
are in China in the public sector Biden
added 51,000 jobs meaning your taxes are
paying for new so-called jobs like IRS
agents employees Donald Trump reduced it
by 3,000 it was a net loss of 3,000
public sector jobs so he had a lower
unemployment rate he had a lower
part-time employment rate he had more
private job growth that wasn't even
close and he actually was the first
president that I know in modern history
who reduced the size of the public
sector plus n plus 51 1,000 jobs with
Joe Biden in the public sector most the
IRS minus 3,000 under Donald Trump and
he still had better job performances
something else to know Donald Trump's
jobs uh his jobs reports when those came
out the economic reports they always had
to adjust them later on because the
numbers were higher than they initially
reported surprise they've always had to
adjust Joe Biden former Vice President
Biden's later on because they're lower
than suggested so time too exactly
that's and that's a consistent through
line not once or twice wages yeah well
Donald Trump the wages close to $5,000
people under years of Obama it was about
$1,200 uh with Joe Biden the actual wage
in it's been a wage decrease when you
adjust for inflation because the
inflation has been so bad it's not just
what they say they are asking this
question NBC on the premise that of
course people are struggling and making
less money let's go here D santis And
His Cowboy I'm going to throw it in the
trash can on day one where it belongs
that is going to give the economy
breathing room and I'm also going to
reign in the Federal Reserve they have
help
Mony what we have faced since
theic they botched it Congress botched
it both parties are to blame fed should
focus on stable prices they are not an
economic get rid of them they should
focus on nothing yep is trying to do
that ways that you can improve people's
Financial condition in the short
term the economic question is core to my
vision policy prescription for this
country increase the supply of of
everything it's the law of supplies and
demand increase the supply of energy
that brings down the cost of energy
grows the economy drill Frack burn coal
and Brace nuclear increase the supply of
labor in this country stop using our
taxpayer money to pay people more to
stay at home instead of to go to work
increase the supply of housing people
don't talk about this when in the
Republican Party the land use
restrictions are constricting the supply
of housing that's making housing more
expensive for ordinary Americans across
this country country so that's the true
answer and I think it takes a CEO in the
White House who actually understands
this to get this done because Americans
at home they know the bomic is a lie
prices are going up interest rates and
mortgages to buy your home are going up
but wages have remained flat that's the
hard diagnosis for our economy and this
is about more than just our economy I
say this as a member of my generation
I'm 38 years old I'm the youngest person
ever to run for US president as a
republican the reason my generation has
lost our sense of pride in part is
because people in my generation feel
like the American dream isn't available
to them and part of the reason why is
we've burdened them with four-year
college degrees that did not serve their
head start on the American dream people
will be more proud of answ we're all
making more money in that country this
is how we revive national pride and our
identity and it will take a CEO in the
white house with zero based budgeting by
the way to take on the thank let me turn
to Governor Christy on that well look
let step on your applause Mr entire
premise of the question and ie on this
is absolutely energy is the key to this
because it drives every one of those
other prices and you're brimming with it
now food gets to your grocery store it
gets trucked and those truckers have to
pay for fuel for the higher fuel prices
and when you go ahead and you tell
people we are going to unleash every bit
of American Energy every bit of its
potential what happens in the Futures
markets the prices go down because those
people who are believing that the Biden
program will continue are the ones who
are bidding this up and let me tell the
other place that's bidding it up in the
Middle East and so if you don't believe
that making sure that Israel and that
Israel situation that's going on right
now isn't resolved and resolved quickly
as two drink because the I stand with
Israel shtick and the fake tough guy
shtick drink bring up the drinking game
rules so people know I'm sorry that our
rules are so effective as well and what
they say is a response to a crisis when
it's really what it's in response to is
putting more money in their pockets when
they have an American president who
knows that Israel must be defended not
with humanitarian pauses and not with
suggestions for ceasefire but with
letting them know we will supply them
with everything they need that will also
bring stability to the market energy is
the key to bringing this down it's what
every American family needs when they
turn on their lights fill up their car
and go to the grocery store and we need
to do that first and foremost that's the
short-term answer Governor Chrissy thank
you Ambassador hilly let me come at this
from a slightly different direction
Americans in rural communities are being
especially squeezed by inflation right
now an Iowa State University study found
that last year inflation cost rural
households about an extra
$5,000 how would you specifically help
rural Americans who are suffering right
now Ambassador well I'm a product of
Rural America I grew up in rural South
Carolina and I can tell you what we're
seeing now in America is the rich are
getting richer and the poor are getting
poorer we have to go and start beefing
up the middle class and the first thing
I would do is I will eliminate the
federal um gas and Diesel tax in this
country we'll cut taxes on the middle
class but we have to stop the spending
binge that's happening by Republicans
and Democrats in Congress I will make
sure one we claw back the $500 billion
dollar of unspent coid dollars that are
out there instead of 87,000 IRS agents
going after Middle America will go after
the hundreds of billions of dollars of
coid fraud that exist one out of every
$7 we'll stop the spending we'll stop
the borrowing we'll eliminate the ear
marks and I'll veto any spending bill
that doesn't go back to pre-co levels
that will cut trillions and allow us to
be safe we also need to be not energy
independent energy dominant we to a
woman talk about not spending money the
reason no one should give you a number
Hue on the amount of sh is because in a
few years our interest expense is going
to be more than our defense budget can
give you that number realistically
without first Scott just a dirty joke
to he was going yeah she did understand
this is a crisis it is a national
security concern if we don't deal with
what's going to happen with that
interest expense in a few years we're
going to look like going use that J oh
my God you get them done already dollar
matters Ambassador thank you very much
Americans could
see Americans could see their social
security benefits drastically cut decade
because the program is running out of
money I think they've done a pretty good
job tonight NC I agree not bad
circumstances should
Republicans Governor Christie first to
you you have proposed raising the
retirement age for younger Americans
what would that age be specifically not
going to make it
105 thr that next sure and we have to
deal with this problem now look if we
raise the retirement age a few years for
folks that are in their 30s and 40s um I
have a son who's in the audience tonight
is 30 years old if he can't adjust to a
fewe increase in Social Security
retirement age over the next 40 years I
got bigger problems with him than his
Social Security payments I love you Dad
the fact is we need to be realistic
about this there are only three things
my son out there sitat 11 12 13
14 retirement age eligibility for the
program in general and taxes that's it
we are already overt taxed in this
country and we should not raise those
taxes but on eligibility also I don't
know if out there tonight and if you're
watching Warren um I don't know if
Warren Buffett is collecting Social
Security but if he is Shane Jimmy Buff
you shouldn't be taking the money there
are a lot of programs in this country
that we all pay for that we don't get a
direct benefit from Food Stamps is one
of them I've never fortunately in my
life ever had me or my family on food
stamps I'm glad it's govern Che so that
no one in this country goes to bed
hungry at night if they have
availability to that program too easy
too easy they live on your block
security remember why it was estblished
I went for a snack it's all gone always
no one would grow old in this country in
poverty that's what we got to get back
moves in it's a food desert Social
Security I woke up last night pizza
crust on my chest cut Social
Security they don't want to talk about
social security if I'm not mistaken you
guys can bring it up I did a video on
this a long time ago where I reported
Social Security to the SEC I believe it
was 16 workers per retiree when they
launched and the average life expect was
about 67 years old now I believe it's
three workers per retiree and the
average life expectancy is 75 years old
a Ponzi scheme is where you have a
financial plan think of like a pyramid
scheme where it requires new people
right new people to pay in the scheme to
pay out the initial investors and the
new people won't be paid out that is
social security but it's a third rail
that even GOP candidates don't really
want to touch because a lot of old
people vote for them so I'm curious to
see if anyone here says look it's
insolvent you go and you say we're going
to change the rules you change the
retirement age for them instead of cost
of living increases we should go to
increases based on inflation we should
limit limit benefits on the wealthy
Bernie Marcus can tell you he hates
getting that check limit the benefits on
the we wealthy and expand Medicare
Advantage plan seniors love that and
let's make sure we do that so can have
more competition That's How we'll deal
with entitlement reform and that's how
we'll start to pay down this debt and
can you give me a specific age have you
determined the age with Chris what I can
tell you is you can it's going to be
those in their 20s just coming into the
system and it should reflect more of
life expectancy it doesn't do that now
all right Mr ramaswami have you
determined he's going to give a clear
answer he's going to say it's not a
thing so forms are you looking at so
this is really important right now we're
working within the last window I believe
we will have to actually fix this
problem while still leaving Social
Security and Medicare benefits for
current seniors intact I'll tell you how
the other candidates assume like Nikki
that it can't be done and on her math
she's right about it but her math
assumes $7 trillion of our $33 trillion
national debt going to fight Wars like
in places like Iraq and Afghanistan
minus that our national debt would be
$26 trillion right now then you go to
zerob based budgeting which I've
proposed as a CEO it's how I've run
businesses it's how many CEOs run
businesses comp to Baseline budgeting
ever heard of construction season on
roads as the Baseline and then ask
what's actually NE Neary 75% headcount
reduction yes that is severe in the
number of federal employees in the
Washington DC bureaucracy shut down
redundant agencies that should not exist
deliver economic growth as a positive
Tailwind I think we can get to three
four maybe even 5% GDP growth if we
really take the regulatory shackles off
of our economy we had we had that
several quarters under Donald Trump you
guys can bring it up how many quarters
do we have that were well over 3% I knew
over well over 4% for quite a few of
them including sacrificing the Foreign
Wars that many bloodthirsty members of
both parties have a hunger for that's
the one secret for how we're going to be
able to do this and that requires
discipline so we can't have the first
conversation we were having sending
foreign aid willy-nilly to countries
whose national debt per capita is less
than ours but if we do this correctly I
think this is our last window and it'll
take a CEO from the Next Generation to
do it thank you very much this popular
it's a it's a very difficult issue for
people to tackle because at some point
you have to rip the Band-Aid off did
they bring in the retiree per per active
worker stat yet I believe it was 16 to1
and it went to 3:1 when I did this video
in
2011 maybe 2010 um it comes down to this
do you really believe in the vision
where they say hey yeah we're not going
to touch your Social Security and this
is something we can do uh forever or or
do you understand that it's simply a
program that was created at a time when
life expectancy was different uh the
entitlement programs that we had as a
general rule were different our policing
the world was very different and our
debt was not at the level that it is now
you have to acknowledge the reality and
I get it you have a lot of Boomer voters
and I'm not insulting Boomers who say
well I paid in well guess what so are
people now especially Mill you have
Millennials who are 40 who've been
paying in and the only way that they get
paid out is if you raid something else
you need to grab another slush fund
that's that's really what we're talking
about so people don't want to address
this head-on remember Rick Perry got in
a lot of trouble because he said that
Social Security was a problem Mitt
Romney went after him I really would
like to see a shift away from that with
the GOP and Vic the only VI is the only
one who answered that in a way that
frankly is somewhat reality based let me
know when they bring in those numbers
2017 what happened Revenue went up by 3%
and the next year it went up by another
3% so what we know is that the laugher
curve still works the lower the tax the
higher the revenue and finally if we're
going to deal with it we have to take
our annual Appropriations referring to
Art laugher the laugher curve if you're
not familiar with it it's the idea that
there's an ideal point where you tax
people where you generate maximum
Revenue I believe his is somewhere
around 30% uh and there's also something
that's more interesting I find uh
housers law I believe it's h ER housers
law where if you look at the amount of
taxes that have been collected over the
last several decades it still is
averaged pretty consistently overall uh
when you average it across income across
uh value added tax all of that 16 to 20%
let's average it somewhere around 18%
the revenue collected doesn't change if
you increase the taxes it remains it
remains remarkably stable as a byproduct
of GDP regardless of the income tax it
stabilizes because if people have higher
income tax they spend less it ends up
being around that number between 16 to
20% kind of no matter what you do this
is something that's boring a lot of
people don't want to discuss but as a
matter of tax policy it is an it is an
unavoidable reality so if you could just
tax people up to 90% Like Bernie Sanders
said was a good thing and that would
generate 90% more Revenue great it
doesn't work so right now look up
Houser's law we have a reference at L
withth credit.com what the oh well
you what happen a lot of seniors
throughout this country so valid point
promise made promise kept I understand
what you're with the rising that's a
screwdriver I'm more of a flathead man
but we'll make sure to what can you do
to help sh up Social Security one of the
things that's that's causing problems is
the inflation we have to reduce
inflation I'm going to be very brief and
and do this so
down to 2 to one okay get to at least 3%
growth you're never going to be able to
have uh issues you can adish me later I
said 16 to one but I guarantee you
that's a study somewhere that had a left
to SL no I don't but I still deserve to
be ad Mish because I didn't I didn't
point out the severity that's because Mr
naps a lot over here you want it okay
didn't happen until you called yourself
on how dry the 2018 Q2 GDP growth under
Trump 4.1% 4.1% they're acting like
that's something they can aspire to
that's Pie in the Sky it was a reality
under Donald Trump think about that
they're saying they could maybe get what
I did all the time imagine if I had four
more years imagine that look that filthy
Nikki Haley doesn't have a
chance maybe 2% GDP that's generous a
lot of people St Peter told me from
Heaven can't get 2.5% GDP by way
since we're talking about Trump clip a
little pump real quick Tim all right
let's do this well she's going to have a
puppet rapper L pump little pump
Li I love it I said how do you pronounce
that they said
liil love it that was perfect all right
well look hey let's take a minute right
now they're going to commercial break we
have the rest of that interview with
vivec I believe that you can play what
you had there um if you can pull that up
in just one second and we will make sure
that we get back to this and any other
Trump stuff that's coming up right and
send in uh into the chat if there's
something you would like to see us cover
between the Trump Town Hall between this
rally sorry the debate if there's
something we're missing let us know
because answer to you mug Club not to a
bunch of corporate donors or uh big Tech
who I'm pretty sure about to suspend us
anyways over the Nashville Manifesto
let's go to America's favorite Indian
and Gerald obtained by the police but
were you surprised at the respon
released this well no they could they
could have very easily released this
given us some information were you
surprised by the response immediately
Google started the the search had like a
blacked out thing saying hey that the
data on this is changing very quickly
they ended up pulling down YouTube
videos for that Reddit ended up blocking
us for it we ended up having Facebook
block like immediately big Tech po
silence can't can't talk about this
can't it I think I think there's a
difference between being surprised and
appalled at this point I'm not surprised
but I'm that I'm nonetheless unsurprised
though I am I'm still appalled and and
that's what moves me to want to lead
this country to set a tone from the top
of the executive branch of the
government to say we're done with this
phase of Our National History we will
set an example anytime a government
actor is pressured a private actor to do
something through the back door or
silence something that the government
couldn't do directly we will publish it
roll that log over let's see what crawls
out it's going to be ugly but we got to
see it first before we fix it whether
that's within this Republican party
whether that's within the Deep state of
the federal government that I'll be
running as the next president if I'm
elected it's any sphere of Our Lives
that's the example we have to set We the
People handle the truth that's the first
step sometimes the truth is ugly you got
to see it if you're to fix it and so
anyway man we're um I probably got to
rock roll pretty soon U you know debate
we'll be back going to pop into where
we're and U see the kids a little bit
have have some food with them and then
we'll be back in the debate tonight that
sounds good and we look forward to
seeing it look if if you're available
post or would like to to come back on to
talk about how the debate went let us
know we'd love to have you but thank you
for taking a few minutes and uh hope you
get some rest enjoy some family time and
uh have a great
debate all right man we tell everybody
said H tell Crowder and crew appreciate
it thanks thank you take take care
bye
[Music]
yeah you like that oh yeah yeah you
actually hit it right on the spot yeah
is that good like literally that is that
is the good stuff right there you want a
little deeper yeah yeah go deeper little
deeper oh yeah harder no just just a
little harder guys what what what's
going on here uh uh just not nothing
just applying this CB Distillery stick
to yakuza's back yeah I got a kink in my
back he's real kinky I don't want to
Kink shame could you keep it down in a
place of work or do it at home yeah sure
no problem yeah we we'll go somewhere
else yeah
okay wait huh is that my CB Distillery
stick I've been looking everywhere for
it you can keep it though I'll just
order my own
it you can keep it and I'll uh order
another one from CB distillery.com if I
use the promo code creder it's 20% off
that's a nice deal do we all get that
deal can I get that deal yeah anyone can
get that deal nice I'll get one you
could put it on my back why would I do
that why would I why would I get a new
one at 20% off only to use it again on
your hairy back well how El you're
supposed to put on my back and I put it
on Yakuza no one has to put it you have
to the back to back it's not an I do
your back and you do yakuza's back I
don't want anything of mine touching
your back ever I don't who's telling you
anything what are you hearing there's
people are talking people they said well
it doesn't it doesn't I don't want to
touch put you want me to put on right
now I don't want that I'm going to order
another one and no one's touching your
back all right bye Stephen
no no go to CB distillery.com and enter
the promo code Crowder for 20% off no
prescription
[Music]
required
next all right we're actually going to
take just a second the debate is coming
back we're going to go to Donald Trump's
rally right now in Florida as well let's
see what he's saying Republicans by the
way anytime you have anytime you have
mailin ballots you are going to have
really corrupt elections but until then
Republicans must win we have to win so
we can do this and in conclusion this is
what we must do to restore our country
to Greatness together we're taking on
some of the most menacing forces and
vicious opponents are our people have
ever seen no matter how hateful or
corrupt the Communists and criminals
were're fighting against may be you must
never forget this nation does not belong
to them this nation belongs to you it
belongs to the people with us tonight
that's how we want it's our land this is
your
home this is your heritage and our
American Liberty is your god-given right
from Tampa to Tallahassee from Pensacola
to
Sarasota from Gainesville to
Jacksonville to Miami we inherit the
legacy of generations of amots who their
blood to defend our country and to
defend our freedom we stand on the
shoulders of American Heroes who cross
the oceans Blaze the trail the ocean
blue tame the Wilderness down the
railroads dug out the Panama Canal
nobody thought it was possible raised
up won two world wars defeated fascism
and communism and he back
to bra
American the American he makes me
believe in positive thinking which I
never believe we whoop the world's butt
again y done it twice sing to the moon
in the history here's the other thing
about him he did all that as a novice
yeah yeah well I mean he didn't win
World Wars as I mean no I'm not talking
about that I'm talking about what he
accomplished all the that they're
saying tonight on stage he already did
and he was brand new at it
yeah I don't think we'll be taken too
much people advice which is
[Applause]
[Music]
fine build it what happened they thrown
somebody out them want
more somebody heckling him can't believe
it yeah oh
yeah well we got Christy back online
there very sad video behind me sad
listen to the music all right let's go
back to the debate really quickly let's
see what tons of fun has to say he's SP
this time I say it loving at the open
ports of our border Customs and Border
Patrol agents are overwhelmed there's
200,000 encounters a month I don't over
the last 11 month he's a big fow look
I'm a big fellow no I'm not talking
about that I just can't trust a
republican from the Northeast I can't
trust a republican invited Obama there
after superstorm stand he gave him a
French kiss on the beach right after
pretty much did yeah remember that oh
yeah you remember
that of Entry now we also need to lower
demand you in this country and the way
to lower demand is to start treating
people again what you know we started to
do this before Co and we haven't done
enough of it and for every family out
there tonight who has lost a loved one
to fentel or to any other type of opioid
overdose what you know is all you want
is a chance for them to win their lives
back slows when I'm president of the
United States we're going to call this
what it is it is a disease like heart
disease diabetes or any other disease
like cancer that can be treated should
be treated we not only have to stop
Supply but we have to lower demand Liv
you'll never do it you'll never do it
you'll never win the drug war stop
acting like you're going to win the drug
war and get people to stop doing drugs
attack the cartels where they
manufacture the chemicals off because
like we're going to do this we're going
to been saying that for 30 years 40
years 50 years I don't know go back as
far as you want to go you're not going
to do it don't don't give me Pie in the
Sky just say this is a battle that we're
probably going to have to deal with for
the rest of our lives and we're going to
have to fight for our loved ones if we
want to keep them from falling victim to
this I have family members that have
dealt with this I understand what it's
like I don't need pie in the sky I need
honest real solutions and I need to
understand the problem but don't tell me
you're going to solve it don't bring pie
into thel and the drug war and and and
what we're going to do for families
we're going to we're going to treat this
we're going to get it taken care of
we're going no you're not Sor look let
me I don't know if you guys brought up
not defe this but you're not going to do
it sorry I don't know if you guys
brought up these stats and I say this as
by the way I just use the CB Distillery
stick it's keeping me afloat so go to CB
distillery.com uh and enter the promo
code crder by the way I used it after
the surgery when they weren't even a
sponsor they're one of the best
companies out there you can trust what's
in there but I will say this with
fentanyl the opioid crisis everyone here
and I say this because I know this a
really really boring oh I had it in the
hospital it is good stuff uh they uh
also deloted morphine everything
morphine my they all have to they all
have to treat this as though it's
something we unilaterally agree upon
this is an unpopular opinion but if you
do the research look opioid deaths have
increased as prescribing has gone down
the vast majority of opioid deaths are
from illicit drugs that are not
prescribed just to be clear street drugs
and the vast majority of people who get
addicted to opioids are people who were
already addicted to another substance to
begin with so we need to be careful with
them however the idea that someone is is
now dying because of a fentanyl overdose
that was prescribed to them because
Timmy went in for a wisdom tooth removal
and became a junkie blowing someone for
a packet of Vicodin is not true that is
not accurate and we now have doctors who
won't even prescribe painkillers to
people who will be in lifelong pain from
say car wrex or being you know trampled
by a Chris Christie so we need to be
honest about the problem that we're
facing the problem we are facing is a
drug trade it's a border crisis it is
not doctors prescribing painkillers to
people who need it I know a lot of and
this is not me in the pocket of big
farmer I think that some doctors are
really neilly of course when we go back
to Purdue you look at oxycotton yep they
were overprescribing it but we have let
the pendulum swing too far the other way
and no one wants to actually call it out
China sends the ingredients to Mexico
they put it together bring it over
border it's it's an act of War yes once
again put the freaking
military enough talk about the wall yeah
put the milit that's where the santis I
you know I love the fact okay Sor I went
off on my my soap box but let's instead
of catch and Deport we'll go to catch
and release I'm sorry instead of Catch
and Release we'll go to catch and Deport
that is the way we'll deal with the
Border those are the things that we have
to do going forward but I do agree with
Chris one of the first things that we
have to do is really focus on mental
health and addiction centers it is
something that is needed in our country
terribly because we don't deal with
mental health and someone who doesn't
get care for mental health falls into
addiction and we owe it to them to treat
it like the cancer that it is Mr
[Applause]
ramaswami Noti they always go to V
whenever someone says
cancer we're talking about this issue is
you know like Ron I've actually met many
parents across this country who have
lost their kids to laced Pharmaceuticals
that have fentanyl in them the only
thing I would ask on I think you'd be on
the same page with me on this let's not
even call that an you mean laced street
drugs are you trying to say that
someone's getting a Norco or a vikin in
LA with fentanyl no we would not call
that an overdose
you'd call it what it is it's closer to
biot terrorism and I say that because as
uniquely relates to this crisis that
does warrant more aggressive means to
deal with it so there's a new
presidential election in Mexico in 2024
people may not be aware of that it's
going to be someone other than oor who
has been a disaster in Mex mentioned me
obliquely in spee steal the fentel
anywhere near the White House well get
out of the way white people
vental that build a good relationship
with that next president of Mexico we'll
use our own military to seal our own
Southern what we need to do is stop
using our military to protect somebody
else's Border Way Around the World when
we're short right here at home get
serious about protecting this border and
then the other thing that hasn't been
discussed is the northern border I'm the
only candidate on the stage as far as
I'm aware keep the Canadians outed the
northern border there was enough fanel
that was captured
just last year to kill 3 million
Americans so we got to just state to
where the
don't just build the wall build walls
can't just complete the wall use the
military toal the SSS cheese for the
building thank you Christen thank you
Hugh let's talk now about last night's
election results abortion rights
supporters saw victories in Ohio and
Virginia following earlier winds in
States like Kansas and Kentucky governor
is first to you how do you this is an
opportunity for someone to cut through
the fog and provide a very clear answer
people try to make it seem like it's oh
abortion is just a losing issue it is a
lack of Direction messaging period and
being outspent I'm really curious to see
how they answer this who was struggling
in Jamaica about 40 years ago 45 years
ago to not have a baby because she was
poor baby wouldn't have opportunity and
she came close to have an abortion but
she decided to have the baby born poor
in Jamaica and the reason I know that
story is because that baby
girl Florida becoming a lawyer and a
judge and I appointed her to the Florida
Supreme Court in August of 2022 we're
better off when everybody counts uh
we're better off when we can promote a
culture of Life at the same time I
understand that some of these states are
doing it a little bit different Texas is
not going to do it the same as New
Hampshire Iowa is not necessarily going
to do it the same as Virginia so you got
to work from the bottom up uh you got to
do a better job on these referenda I
think of all the stuff that's happened
to the pro-life cause they have been
caught flat-footed on these referenda
and they have been losing the referenda
a lot of the people who were voting for
The referenda are Republicans who would
vote for a republican candidate so you
got to understand how to do that but
let's just be clear the Democrats have
taken a position they will not identify
the point at which there should be any
protection all the way up until birth
that is wrong and we cannot stand for
that all right Governor DeSantis thank
you Ambassador Haley let me have you
weigh for president Trump has
consistently blamed the abortion issue
and how Republican candidates have
talked about it for their electoral
losses how do you see the path forward
you I've said it before I think you have
to be honest with the American people
this is a personal issue for every woman
and every man I am unapologetically
pro-life not because the Republican
Party tells me to be but because my
husband Michael was adopted and I had
trouble having both of my children so
I'm surrounded by
blessings put in your vagina post row
wrong was made right they took it out of
the hands of unelected justices and they
put it in the hands of the people and
now we're seeing States vote and what
I'll tell you is as much as I'm pro-life
I don't judge anyone for being
pro-choice and I don't want them to
judge me for being pro-life so when
we're looking at
this on the pro-life side I welcome that
there's some states that are going more
on the pro-choice side I wish that
wasn't the case but the people decided
but when it comes to the federal law
which is what's being debated here be
honest it's going to to take 60 Senate
votes a majority of the house and a
president to sign it so no we
haval in over a hundred years we might
have 45 pro-life Senators so no
Republican president can ban abortions
any more than a Democrat president can
ban these state laws so let's find
consensus let's agree on what how we can
ban late term abortions here's the issue
is is is Ron Des santis he didn't get an
Applause because he just sort of
curtailed that it should be look I think
it should be it should be the owners
should be on the left and Democrats to
identify where life begins or there
should be limitations and if they don't
well then they're going to deal with the
boot of the state legislature and now
we're not going to be outspent 2 to1
we're going to outspend them 3 to1
educating the public as to what
constitutes a life that may require
fetal charts I don't know but the truth
is most people when they actually
understand the left's policy they
disagree with it they obfuscate their
policy we need to be transparent with it
and of course this goes to State's
rights which is really what you're
looking at when you're talking about the
overturning of roie weight but let's
make sure I challenge anyone today on
this stage Joe Biden Camala Harris run
through the list say to Define when life
begins or where they would place any
limitation on abortion that is an answer
that they are required to provide put it
on them that's where the Republicans
have been so flat footed with it where
they go you just want well they the were
Democrats haven't given that answer and
they're still winning I know well that's
because the media never challenged them
the media never challenges them but it's
your job to do it because now if you do
that here today it gets it gets posted
everybody it gets disseminated across
social media and then there's some
pressure because you know what a lot of
people are sharing this clip and really
we haven't provided an answer the media
is not going to do it cut through the
fog yourself that should be the Focus
right now Ronda sent has kind of added
it there as an addendum didn't spend
enough time on it sorry I'm interrupting
Tim Scott and I know you all desperate
to hear him no he would have knocked me
out I think it's unth unethical and
immoral to allow for abortions up until
the day of birth we have an opportunity
in this
to St I don't think they're going to say
anything super interesting but there's
only about 17 minutes left in this
debate they're all going to give their
flying butterfly in the Luna commercial
we do need to see if we can check back
in with finegan and see if he ever
actually found his way into the arena is
that I need to look at my I know we have
the seven plus one after this and Alex
Jones of course providing a postgame
wrapup uh let me check my map here all
right oh oh so we do we
have okay yeah we have Thomas finigan on
the ground yeah okay
[Music]
hi Stephen wow okay so you are really uh
there at the debate thank you um I'm
impressed good job finegan who do you
have lined up for an interview for
us well it's been kind of a long day and
uh I haven't had anything to drink yet
I'm rather parched so I I'm going to
head back to my motel I'll try again in
the morning no no no don't do that at
all you're there you're there there's no
debate in the morning okay it's now look
behind you just just wait it out here
just tough it out grab someone and go my
nails are getting kind of Wy I'm going
to have to give those a finegan no
finegan no what are you doing what are
you doing finegan come on look this is
one of those times buck up you're right
parked over here a okay cut it I
just can't
[Music]
even I'm pardon my language just so many
of you have signed up for mug Club after
the Nashville Manifesto the promo code
undercover it's still $10 off and I
don't want you to think that all of your
money is going to to fin we have him on
retainer that's been legac in salary I'm
just he was really cheap I want to watch
VI talk about the abortion issue because
there's N9 billion of them I was that
Radio Shack parental consent why it's
back to that Republican culture of
losing the Republicans did not have an
alternative Amendment or Vision on the
table I know Ohio was born raised and I
liveed there it's representative of the
country if in the state of
oh access to adoption here the missing
ingredient in this bring up the drinking
game rules there are only 17 minutes
left to be carried to the ICU we live in
an era of reliable genetic paternity
tests that are 100% reliable so we can
say men deserve more responsibility so
we can tell women we're all in this
together it's not men's rights versus
women's rights it's about human rights
and I've come back to that case that
Clarence Thomas spoke of a pregnant
woman walking down the street she's
assaulted the unborn child dies in that
assault you find me one person in this
country who says that that criminal does
not deserve liability for that death you
won't find one that says we share the
same instincts on this issue but we
require I believe a different generation
leaders to actually lead us forward un
the country on this honesty thank you Mr
ramaswami Governor Chris WR now let's
see if they do the orbit camera with
Chris gry they've done it for no one
else and what I think it's a cameraman
screwing with them it's a years um
conservative lawyers arguing that the
federal government should have
absolutely nothing to do with this issue
constitutionally because it's nowhere in
the Constitution and then dos comes and
we finally gain that Victory which was
the creation of a constitutional right
out of thin air that didn't exist and
now we have people running to say let's
short circuit the States from doing what
they need to do and let's go right to
some type of federal ban at a certain
number of weeks and people have on the
stage have been all over the place 20
weeks 15 weeks 12 six look numbers
that's the frers were really smart
they're doing the this is an
issue what the hell and I
trust the camera state by state a drone
they did it for no one else in Oklahoma
you can't get an abortion unless the
life of the mother is at risk in my home
state of New Jersey it goes up to 9
months since you get an abortion I find
that morally
reprehensible that is what the people of
our state of poison the kids Halloween
Camp did a couple years that process
until every
state Chris chrisy would just be filled
with poison yeah exactly the bigger
issue is and Tim began to tou we know
when the procedure is over will you hear
the kids lunch boox Hit the Floor to be
Pro treat with
pillowcases I use an industrial trash
bag we should get treatment for her to
rest her life the 52-year-old who's drug
addicted should make sure that any of
his children who he's passed that
Addiction on to are treated well too Pro
life's not just in the womb Kirsten it's
for the whole life that's a leftist
talking point you fat son of a
everything I was like being pro- life
doesn't mean pay for all the free stuff
by stealing through taxpayers for Jersey
governor it's about his Republican they
taking a bit of a break here we can
Donald Trump I think has wrapped up by
this point yeah so he's wrapped we
covered a couple of the the highlights
from him but we do have the seven plus1
that we need we do the S Plus we might
want to do it after we want to go to the
Hillary Clinton stuff from The View
where they yeah I think we should do let
me make sure I have these clips lined up
uh what do we have oh okay so here was
and by the way the promo code is
undercover thank you so much let me just
reiterate this because there's been a
lot of false reporting on the Nashville
Manifesto um just to be clear no one was
paid for that story our source has been
protected we will protect them we will
be willing to go to jail for our source
our source is not one of the seven were
put on administrative not one of the
seven put on administrative leave
despite what questionable journalists
have tried to tell you uh and a big by
by the way just so you know a big goal
of that is to intimidate whistleblowers
into silence our whistleblower is as
safe as in their mother's arms you can
send in your tips to lwc tips at
protonmail.com we will protect it and it
actually is a testament to how great of
a job the undercover unit has done here
the investigative journalism unit
because they put seven people on leave
and they messed
up hey mnpd go go try try try again
life sucks get a helmet
there you
go I love that Dennis ly line that
classic iconic line you know that he
used all right uh here's Hillary Clinton
who went on The View today I guess wow
and uh she lumbered onto the view and
said that a trump 2024 Victory would
mean the end of America as we know it
your lost to Trump in um 2016 will go
down in history is one of the most
pivotal times in our country one of the
most pivot moments in our country um and
it's still reeling
from you know Trump's policies I think
um and the Deep divisions that he swed
in this country what in your view would
happen if he were to be reelected oh I
can't even I can't even think that
because I think it would be the end of
our country as we know it what yes shut
up a thing yeah
okay uh anyone anyone have any response
no I hope she dies in
a thick ankle I a Qui question
um did our did our country end when he
beat you the first time yeah funny
enough it did it did better funny enough
hey did did he leave office even though
he thought the election was stolen well
she did go on to clarify just to she
substantiated she showed her work um I
mean she was
panting she explained why a second Trump
term would be worse than and I want to
make sure I'm reading this correctly she
compared him she did she compared him to
Hitler wow original now he is going to
if he were ever near the Oval Office
again find people who have no principles
no conscience who are
totally you know to his fortunes
literally and therefore would do
whatever he said and so the the wreckage
is almost unimaginable you know when I
was Secretary of State I used to talk
about one and done and what I meant by
that like you and Clinton with get
legitimately elected good one and then
they would try to do away with
and do away with opposition and do away
with a free press and you could see it
in countries where well Hitler was duly
elected right and so all of a sudden
somebody with those Tendencies though
dictatorial authoritarian Tendencies
would be like okay we're going to shut
this down we're going statement from
someone dressed like a guard at trinka
and they didn't usually Telegraph that
Trump is telling us what He intends to
do take him at his word the man means to
throw people in jail who disagree with
him shut down legitimate press Outlets
do what he can to literally let me just
be really clear here okay let's look at
the political opponents of Donald Trump
who were put in jail I'm counting them
up you can bring this up as a reference
uh zero with uh former Vice President
Biden you have Douglas Macky the meme
maker in jail the meme maker in jail you
have the proud boys right and by the way
you have the doj pushing for more
aggressive sentencing even though they
weren't involved with any type of
insurrection on January 6th you have
Owen tryer who I believe is back in
solitary confinement now if I'm not
mistaken and of course they're trying to
jail Trump in four states one of the
biggest criticisms against Donald Trump
is that he didn't lock her up that
that you see right there right he didn't
jail his political opponents the doj
under Joe Biden Donald Trump how many
times has he been indicted how many
political dissidents has Donald Trump
put in jail this is the fear-mongering
from the left this is projection they
accuse you of doing exactly what it is
that they do we'll go back to it I know
I know you get riled up with
the free speech and shutting
down you know the laptop story and all
that every they there they go it's gonna
be the end of democracy and they they've
already ended it well so one of the
things I want to ask really quickly and
Tim Scott's giving some statements here
guys and and and look I'm not no
disrespect to Tim Scott but we're
probably not going to see him on the
debate stage after this in my opinion uh
but she is she's bold prediction cotton
I know right show me one thing that
Trump said where he was serious about
never giving up power again show me one
time where he said I'm never going to
leave office if you elect me I'll stay
president forever there was a joke of a
meme of Time Magazine joking yes of
course but these guys are like he's told
us what he's going to do and I'm like
she's accusing him of doing exactly what
she did she's saying because he
questioned the election results which
she did for four years 2016 in Russia
for crying out loud she she orchestrated
she she had op research he's never said
anything about shutting down media in
fact he's trying to expand media right
now he's just saying that you guys are
fake news this is a guy whose son has a
show on Rumble I know all right let's
hear let's hear uh Mr French I'm running
for president United States because I'm
tired we not running I'm tired of seeing
the division I'm tired of seeing the
anger and I could see in the eyes of
Americans their exhaustion cut the ex
the petty personal politics that have
taken over this country over the last
number of years I'm running for
president to be a president of
he's doing the things to make sure that
America's role in the world stays number
one that we stand up for our friends and
allies really around the world and we
stand up for what we believe in right
here at home and the 2% of you in the
primary agree with me our differences
has always been our strength as a
country oh shut not our weakness but you
can't truly say of his talking points
from the left yes every American and the
other half is the menu at Golden Corral
let me guess diversity is our strength
yes it's our downfall the over we
deserve and should accept nothing less
Governor thank you very much let's go to
Mr rosam nowby one
minute we've talked a lot about Foreign
Wars tonight but we're in the middle of
a war right here at home yep it's a war
not between black and white or Democrat
and Republican it's between those of us
who believe in our founding ideals and
love this country and a fringe minority
who hates the United States of America
and I think it's going to take a
commanderin-chief to lead us to victory
in that war who first of all knows that
we're in a war second of all can't be
captured by the special interests along
the way but third is from the Next
Generation somebody with fresh legs to
lead us to Victory I'll shut down the
Deep State I'll declare economic
independence from China I'll keep us out
of World War III and then revive
national pride in this country I also
want to close with one message to the
Democrat Party end this farce that Joe
Biden is going to be your nominee we
know he's not even the president of the
United States he's a puppet for the
managerial class so have the guts to
step up and be honest about who you're
actually going to put up so we can have
an honest debate Biden should step aside
end his candidacy now so we can see
whether it's Nome or Michelle Obama or
whoever else running the country now so
we can have an whoa put up or shut up he
just he just put the good for him thank
you m drop hit the ding that's a mic
drop thank you she's got to follow world
is on fire TJ Max we have a war in
Europe we've got a war in the Middle
East we've got China on the March it is
very important that we know how to
defend our freedoms and how to defeat
terrorism and
socialism we put on your between good
and EV have to know the difference
between right and wrong we need to know
that a strong America doesn't start wars
a strong America prevents Wars and the
way we can focus on that is to make sure
we go back to the soul of America and be
strong and proud again and we can't do
that can't win the fights of the 21st
century with politicians from the 20th
century we have to move forward and we
can do this I know we can do this so
join our mve you may disagree funniest
man alive right here right next to once
again show what America and proud looks
like God bless nikk the is broken what
happened Governor de santis you're
closing you have one minute we must
reverse our country's Decline and that
is going to require leadership I will
take the hits I will take the arrows I
will take the bars it's not about me
this is why STIs is not doing very well
it's because his advisor say use this
line yeah man yeah it went great no one
can touch you when you said I will take
the arrows I will take the hits why am I
saying slings slings is what they use to
throw the things no no you'll take the
slings you'll take the slings you sling
as president as the father of three
young kids I'm going to ensure that this
country is Left To The Next Generation
in better shape than we found it and as
the governor of Florida I delivered on
all my promises you can trust me to
deliver for you go keep doing that for a
little while I think he should stay for
your vote he's a good Governor he's a
fantastic Governor one of the best the
election I will be a leer a good
president he usually does he just may
not be ready right now his campaign
hasn't been great God bless you governor
thank you well the tongue thing was a
little weird tongue thing was they're
going to meme that yep it's like a goat
sticking out its
tongue that is going to conclude our
debate U the next line says if the
audience can hold the Applause that
didn't work out but anyway for just a
few more seconds I'll ask you to just
hold the
Applause moderators I want to thank the
candidates for their time and for this
spirited debate really good deep
conversation and we appreciate you all
being here thank you as well to our
wonderful host here at the AG and our
Performing Art Center on behalf of the
Republican National Committee and all of
us at NBC news good night
everyone Chris Christie the buffet is
now open yes it is I hope they have
shrimp they got good
shrimp is it is it Dev vined oh let's be
honest I don't give a I'll eat the
vein I could see a sandwich in his
thing it was the sandwich in his
Podium if you brought to you by Jersey
miks all right uh I am curious the
coverly we'll go to the coverage the
post coverage here on the main news
outlets and then afterwards we going to
have Alex Jones on on mug club for the
Post debate Roundup but I guess this is
as good a time as Andy Andy to do the
seven I've had two and a half drinks
over the course of the evening that is
it just to be clear but the drinking
game is far too effective we're going to
have to scale that back yeah uh Hey
might as well we have this chat they've
been asking for it it's time for
tonight's 7 plus
one
you forgot thean in the chamber just
during that Stinger I said you have one
he goes I can't
read BL who are you Tim Scott I'm blind
hold on what page on 7 plus one I can
you know you can read off my page 7 plus
one tonight things the GOP candidates
are doing in Florida after the debate
separate number seven even though he
wasn't at the debate I just realized
this uh number seven Mike P will be
spending some much needed quality time
with mother on the
homestead oh the fly yeah good for him
that's a multi multi-layer joke uh I
figure this one this one's a layup
because Nick depalo is just filling he
just filled the brim with hate he did s
plus1 things GOP candidates are doing in
Florida after the debate number six
Chris Christie will be rewarding himself
by eating a nice Cuban there you go Bo
oh hey oh don't do gay William like that
that's not nice
that's things GOP candidates are doing
after the debate number five Gerald
Nikki Haley will be raising campaign
funds through a new only fans a new only
fans different from her previous only
fans that one's being shuttered Play No
ChatterBait for her uh number four Ronda
santis will be shopping uh for new BOGO
boots I'll be doing that with lifts how
did this make the
cut all right I don't know number I sent
you some gold I don't see any of here
I'm sorry this is this is my fault hey
I'm here for the paycheck that GOP
candidates are doing in Florida after
the debate number three vrma Swami will
be updating his application to maro's
tech support oh that's true
mine have you tried unplugging it uh
number two Tim Scott will be going back
to his Grassroots so that's nice right
there oh well hey hey that seems like
there's some big Who's That Girl
Builder number one the things that the
GOP candidates will be doing after this
debate Gerald Morgan Nikki Haley will be
demanding to speak to the debates
manager well yeah that makes yeah she's
going to be
upset is that a John and Kate Plus Eight
merged bit with Nikki Haley that is wow
that looks real and the plus one Chris
Christie will be hammock back to tank
number two for his 11: p.m. feeding of
mackerel that
one
this has been seven
[Music]
plus you forgot thean in the chamber all
right so really quickly here uh we we
seemed so we talked about this and uh VI
called them out and said look he's not
going to be running uh so we probably
need to talk about this uh but Nome is
actually losing big support in
California right now he he's been trying
to kind of increase his profile abroad a
new poll that came out said he is uh
he's being humbled right now uh so he
had an 11o drop from his approval rating
in February 11 points really California
it's pretty bad woof doesn't matter yeah
no it matters all the polls are fake
people are appointed do you think
telling you no here's you both think
that it won't be Joe Biden you both
think it won't be Jo but let me ask you
this if his points have gone down by 11
you're saying 11 points do you think
they might uh kind of pull out the
contingency plan and it could be like a
Gretchen Whitmer no I don't think
anybody trying to make it look
interesting folks that's all you don't
think they'll go maybe believe think
they want a woman even before that when
they did the recall on on Nome yeah do
you really think that he that he won
that he won I don't know no I know that
someone threw someone threw a banana pie
at Larry Elder and I thought that was
pretty
shitty was it banana I think someone
someone was dressed up as a gorilla and
threw a pie at Larry Elder I'm like how
is this not front page this is I mean
this is it checks every box for a hate
crime they call him the black face of
white supremacy yeah the black face of
white supremacy told you he's going to
get swor in behind a quickmart as the
Grand Dragon they're showing VI's family
that's pretty okay that's you got a good
looking and by the way V was here spent
time with him enjoyed my time with him
he's a very spry guy VI like he's a guy
who will live forever you need that
energy absolutely I mean you need that
energy to be good look at you know you
know what it's interesting to always
have him on screen with Tim Scott to see
who's actually dark
but uh it just depends on you know
depends on the season let's see what
they're saying here at NBC and maybe uh
if someone can bring to us if there have
been any type of meltdowns I don't think
tonight was enough of a bombshell uh
evening for MSNBC or CNN to lose their
minds Tim Scott their criticisms of
Donald Trump In Praise of his presidency
because they're trying to give a
permission structure to his voters to
say yes I liked him then or like
elements of what he did then even if
he's not the candidate for me now and
that's based in of a factual basis based
on some of our own polling which is
found that attacking Donald Trump
directly can make a candidate less
holding the microphone any direction but
his face F out of your nipples if I were
to be him right now I'd be like hey guys
uh the debate tonight was get that away
from me make it further I think uh yeah
what's he
doing he's being an idiot it's like it's
like a boom and a porn he's got AEL mic
too so it's all just a visual a do that
I think all of them are making similar
calculations about trying to be the last
person standing or hoping someone else
will do the dirty work for them and if
we end this election cycle if we end
this primary cycle with Donald Trump
once again as the Republican nominee I
think debates like this one huge stages
with lots of eyeballs on them primary
with Donald Trump as a candidate draw
more direct contrast with the front
runner who's been squashing them in
state and National polls is going to be
part of the reason why we could end up
in that same place like we saw in 2015
into 2016
can can I say something yes you may
we're all we all seem to be including
the media and everybody assumes that
Trump is not going to be in jail or he's
not going to be in jail I very much
doubt they could make that happen before
the election it could but I don't think
they will you want to start you want to
start we've talked about this you want
to set off the revolution you want to
light the match I don't believe it white
people too fat and lazy it should have
started after the last election I'm
telling you man I understand but too
many promises were made about how
quickly we were going to get to the
bottom of all this that that didn't come
true and people are like well I don't
know who I can believe right now but if
you throw Donald Trump in jail and keep
him from being the nominee all bets are
off it it takes away for does take away
their leg to stand on and saying he
wants to jail political opponents if
they do it and that's something that
they really need to use for
fearmongering so I think they just want
to flick the jab out there to make it
too expensive to just you know have have
enough anchors around his neck and you
know that's what they want to do I don't
think they really want him in jail but
but they might it depends how close we
get to the election if they're out for
blood yeah abolutely boy it's a it's
quite a bluff no I think he's I think
he's the guy I think right now like
after seeing this debate I think VI got
some of his Swagger back he he came out
fighting he called balls and Strikes on
hold on a second this is the worst
hairpiece I've ever seen in my life and
then it just fell flat and went away
moments tonight where people had some
zingers for each other he makes Frank
L's wig look like it's designer Frank's
got a wig why all right sorry continue
Gerald I just I was distracted no but I
I think what should happen right now is
Ronda santis should bow out of this
campaign he should pause his campaign
because if Donald Trump for some reason
can't run if they succeed in kind of
putting him in jail or something else he
can always pick his campaign right back
up he can pause his campaign right now
put his Trump behind Donald Trump or
support behind Donald Trump go back to
being a great governor for a little
while longer and then be the guy in four
years that's what he should do but he
won't right now they're going to keep
running we're going to have one more
debate and our issue right now is the
guy the guy do we have to cover the next
debate and by the way just so you guys
know people are obviously they have
debate fatigue because we have been
tonight blowing away the actual GOP
debate numbers and they're lower than
any debate we've covered because the
truth is there's not that much more to
cover this is really more an exercise
this this is mental masturbation for
these candidates left it's an ego trip
look we're at the point where we should
be able to make a decision I understand
it we have different ideas we want to we
want to narrow the field we go through
the process but at a certain point there
is a fin amount of money and I just want
to know who is giving their money to
Chris Christie that's exactly I would I
would vote for anyone on that stage not
named Chris Christie maybe Nikki Haley I
don't trust her I don't dislike her but
I don't trust her I would not vote for I
would I wouldn't vote for Chris Christie
I would if it's Chris Christie I
wouldn't vote I'm just gonna say that
people say oh St no if it's Chris
Christie I wouldn't vote come on you
guys can comment are you in that same
camp anyone on there I would vote for
not Chris Christie I would like it to be
obviously Donald Trump Ronda santis
maybe V I think he might be better in
some kind of a cabinet position I I
agree I mean he's he's still honestly
he's my favorite candidate of the group
um only because again I think Ronda
santis could be a phenomenal
presidential candidate if he has some
more seasoning I I don't know what
happen I don't I I don't understand what
you guys think he's doing so wrong this
is why I don't yes he incredibly robotic
incredibly kind of the normal cand ofy
the more robotic than a than a than a
Nikki Haley a Chris chrisy would just
put left wi talk but the expectations
were much higher for dis remember
everyone thought it was I know but but
it seems like it it's been a um it's
been the media has sort of done a number
on him that's that's true I I I don't
understand why he's so far down the look
I don't think he's that far down I think
well I read something he's like seven
yeah he's not doing very well but he has
the wrong handlers he's you know what
happens with a lot of but what do you
want him to do differently is what I'm
saying when he's on you know what you
know what these guys need to speak do
what Donald Trump does and every and
then throw the leash off and just be
yourself Let your freak flag F that's
who he is no but he didn't come out that
way Nick that the problem was he
launched his campaign and he went right
towards the Romney style of campaigns he
went right towards the old kind of not
not in policy but in presentation in
presentation and how he presented
himself and how he aligned himself and
what he did and what he said that's the
problem the fire burner this guy that
would go out and just spit fire at the
media and have a phenomenal record did
not come out of the gate swinging I'm
like oh he's going towards the middle
he's gonna be controlled by the RNC he
going to be controlled by these agencies
again and I don't want that in my
nominee Donald Trump's not vivx not but
you guys are you guys are you're basing
it on previous president you saying his
presentation
stinks it should want to be you're
asking for the same you want them
to present thems like every I think that
people should present themselves less
presidentially as far as like in other
words Donald Trump proved it people want
someone who sure you can be professional
but you also have to show a little more
pass what could he I mean what could he
say anymore I don't find as reserved as
you guys stuff you said tonight I'd like
to see if it's like a little bit of
Nicko like a you here's here's a
good example you know I would I know
right here's a good example Viv last
debate versus this debate last debate
he's like and I agree with all my
friends stage I'm not talking about I
know but I'm giving you the comparison
this debate he came out throwing punches
when Ronda Sanz throws punches that's
the Ron that we like give me an example
of him throwing punches that he didn't
throw tonight he threw more tonight than
he has in the past but that's the whole
problem he launched his campaign in a
way that really turned people off put
too much weight on presentation I put
weight on content I like what he's
saying I like his ideas
presentation this isn't show business no
we're just answering your question as
far as why he's falling in the polls I
know but I know and I'm trying to break
the I think he would be I think he would
be a good president establishment
influence is what we're pushing back
against not just presentation it's not
like I'm looking like oh can this guy
act that's not the point the point is
why did he get there it's because he
didn't have the experience the balls or
whatever I don't think it's the balls I
think it's the experience to stand up to
these guys and go that's not who I am
I'm going to be me and if people don't
like me I'll go back to being the
governor where they do like me he was
talking about what he did with Co and
all that stuff in the first debate well
okay let me give a clear example for
example when he would be doing these
press conferences in Florida he would
say remember the the famous one he said
no no you you you you misrepresented me
I disabused you of that notion and I'm
going to go answer another question he
could do that when he command yeah he
was in command he just seems to be going
along to not upset comparing him by
himself at a what I'm saying is people
wanted the Ronda Sanz who we all covered
and we saw at the press conferences to
come out in a national campaign and
we're still we're left wanting I think
is what we're saying a little bit but I
like him and I would vote for him in a
heartbeat one of the best Governors I'm
just trying to sort of reverse engineer
why and you know what you guys can
comment below hit the like button if
you're on YouTube you know most of you
are on Rumble which is great uh but
comment and let us like why do you think
he's been slipping in the polls maybe we
are missing the best thing Trump's got
going he can say I didn't even know what
I was doing I was a novice and I was a
great president now I know what I'm
doing I'm waiting for him to jump on
that line you know um no I think I think
you're all right do we have we we have
Alex I believe so let's let's see I'm
curious to see what he let's bring up
for a post for a post debate wrap up I
thought for one by the way yeah oh yeah
let's call who do you think AB Ely V
there no question I thought he was
tremendous probably VI I do think I do
think Des santis actually had a pretty
good night better than he's had in
better than he's had in the past but
tonight probably VI if you're going to
go by the audience response but let's
start this with Alex Jones and we'll
continue on mug Club post debate wrap
[Music]
up Mr Jones Mr Jones can you hear me sir
yes I've been watching for several hours
this is even better than your last
coverage and that's why you got bigger
numbers uh than the actual debate had
and that's really the big story here is
that independent real media is more
popular than the dinosaur media and then
there's just so many angles here so many
points and it's not just that Vivic come
on your show and come on my show that
I'm saying he won the debate I think
anybody watching this hands down saw
that all the candidates including to Sis
uh were just very very stale I mean I
don't hate the sis I like a lot of
things the sis has done I don't like to
hold Trump to Santa his fight but Nikki
Haley looked like she was on Aderall uh
Scott was just a bunch of Cann garbage
of course Chris Christie is just a
Democrat machine talking point Vivic
really gave a lot of depth and
understanding of things and the way he
called out that was the Mike drop moment
as you guys said when he called out n
Biden said this guy's a puppet of the
administrative deep State we're going to
abolish the Deep state that was
beautiful a lot of the other things he
said were really important we have over
a 100,000 people a year dying of fentel
it's only growing and and it's true back
in the 80s a few people got killed was
like seven or eight when people poisoned
Tylenol they called it poisoning the
Tylenol and if somebody
killed 12,000 or whatever it was last
year with fentanyl that's just where it
was actually diagnos probably much
higher we all know people that have died
of fentanyl or friends that have family
that's died they smoke a a vape it's got
in or they think they're taking ecstasy
it kills them or it's in marijuana it's
or or kids are plant the playground and
get on their hands and uh die and and
and so imagine if one person had fentel
stuck in a Big Mac and be national news
story because it's poisoning and it is a
chemical attack he called it a bio
attack no fenel is a chemical that
biologically can kill humans and is
incredibly strong and and so yes this is
a bio attack but because the globalist
in the left wants open borders and
because they want to depopulate us
they're allowing it all to happen and
that's the other big takeaway here is
that the the and of course the sanas
made this point I believe it was the sis
the the the life expectancy of the
United States is dropping straight down
it's not just fentel it's come out it's
the co shots it's in the insurance
company actuaries so Vivic didn't just
win this he was the only person that
really said anything that was not a
canned talking point from the political
donor
[Music]
so
considering the polls of Donald Trump in
the swing states do you still maintain
that it absolutely and this is what V
said tonight which should be shocking to
a lot of people in the media because the
mainstream media has never even
acknowledged this really a possibility
that uh do you still maintain Alex Jones
that uh Biden will not be the nominee
this
election I 100% agree with you and the
rest of your great pundits there but
it's two different worlds if Biden has
his way and he's trying to not be a
puppet even though he is one that has to
take naps every day and they all these
drugs I've talked to some of the Secret
Service it's it's it's unbelievable he
believes he's the president even though
it's now even come out on NBC News that
what we were told years ago is true
Obama has his own White House Down the
Road and is literally enjoying his third
unelected term to be clear he may have a
house that's white but yes your point
remains well I mean I mean the point is
it's now confirmed that the entire
administrative State around to Obama
this is the third term of these guys and
his vice president is in there as a
placeholder and Obama bragged that's
what he wanted when he left office so
here we are and so Biden's refusing to
leave you've got Axel rod and all the
rest of the top Democrats on TV over the
weekend saying he must leave he must go
they've already finally indicted his son
a hunter of the crackhead that is a
message to him and so if he's able to
hold on and not have a stroke or die in
the next few months or if they don't
assassinate him and blame on the right
winger which I've been saying is in the
cards then yes he's crazy enough to
actually assert himself with his wife
Jill who reportedly is encouraging him
not to leave so that he can still
pretend to be the president and I guess
in some weird way if he can beat the
beat the the Deep State who gives him
his orders but still refuse that order
and stay in power uh which is what
always happens with tyrannies they start
infighting then yes they're crazy enough
Biden's crazy enough and his little
group around him to actually put him in
office again so I would give it a I'd go
from about a 95% chance that he wouldn't
be the nominee to about a 65 70% but but
but yes I don't know if they've got the
balls to actually set up a truck bomb or
a
[Music]
shooting
p
[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
oh
p
[Music]
up
oh
[Music]
n